New York City has implemented what is
the most Draconian lockdown we have ever
seen you now if you live in New York
City need to have two vaccinations if
you want to use any public accommodation
except for some exceptions now all
private sector workers must be fully
vaccinated and all children ages 5 to 11
will need to have one dose of the
vaccine and this is where it gets a
little murky uh do these 5 to 11 year
olds need to have their IDs on them as
well because the decree as was put out
by uh de Blasio stated not only did you
need a vaccination card you needed an ID
so what are parents going to get their
kids id'd or how is this going to work
this is the most extreme mandate we have
seen in the country and it certainly
won't be the worst uh we've seen yet or
I should say only yet because it will
likely get worse over in Europe in
Germany Austria they are implementing
outright lockdowns for those who are
unvaccinated and it's resulted in
rioting which has been going on for the
past several weeks and likely will
continue and I and I think I don't know
what will happen in New York City
because the deeply blue place where
everybody's just seems to be on board
with getting you know three or four
vaccines or whatever but I think if this
spreads Beyond New York City into other
areas you might actually see these
protests but it is very strange in
Florida they don't have these rules so
you know people are mostly just living
free and people are flocking to Florida
in places like Texas so we'll read into
all that we'll see what's going on we've
got Devin Nunes he's retiring
um because of Donald Trump's New Media
Venture which apparently is doing a
distribution deal with Rumble so this is
big big news in the big Tech alternative
media ecosystem maybe some good news
maybe some bad news and then we got a
bunch of news about juicy smolier he
testified today Justice mollet for those
that don't know the Dave spell joke and
Alec Baldwin so we're going to get in
all of this stuff and break it down for
y'all joining us today back again Mr
Daniel Turner always great to be here
thank you very much Daniel trying to
power the future Daniel Turner PTF it's
great to be here thanks for coming back
for like the 50th time yes we always
love having you around thank you
and uh I'm here yeah um and uh I'm
wearing one of my favorite t-shirts that
I absolutely love to wear it was really
fun wearing this t-shirt in Austin since
there's a lot of Communists and
conservatives there I remember meeting a
young I think I think he was a communist
because when he first saw my shirt and
he saw the picture of Karl Marx he was
excited and Giddy and talking and then
Midway he read the the headline of what
it says here and it says a quote from a
homeless man which says and and I reach
to you carefully gives me that's and
then his demeanor change and the guy he
got all weird and then he was like okay
and then he didn't want to help me
around the store a conservative kind of
like jeered at me like Ugh and then he
like finally read the shirt and he was
like I love this shirt it's freaking
awesome and if you want this shirt you
could get it officially on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com and support
me and my efforts that way and Ian I
have to say you look like you got jumped
by some Teletubbies recently are you
okay I feel like a snow cone
I love it Tim actually found these at
the store amazing and just felt
compelled to uh dress me up oh yeah yeah
dude I love this outfit man it's super
warm I don't know if it's a fleece or
something it's like what is it like it
it looks like sherbet yeah
when you get that scoop yeah yeah the
beanie's got a mushroom on it and he's
wearing an orange beanie with a mushroom
I was like look at this mean it's got a
mushrooms it's got a mushroom I can't I
like it I dig it I'm jealous it's so
warm dude
I want to see the hood up eventually oh
yeah there's a hood on it too you look
like a scoop of ice cream look at this I
love it oh sure but though oh my gosh oh
my gosh
[Music]
okay well I look really boring compared
to Ian I'm just wearing my black sparkly
sweater I really like these colors I'm
also here in the corner pushing buttons
very excited for another Monday night
with you guys yeah we're gonna talk
about the news before we get started
head over to timcast.com we're gonna
have a members only segment coming up
for members only around 11 or so p.m as
a member you're supporting all our
Fierce and independent journalism we got
a bunch of we just hired another
reporter to do more news and we launched
a new show on pop culture a little rough
around the edges but we're getting it
going talking about movies TV shows and
we're trying to build culture and get
those ideas out there so your support as
a member helps us expand and do more
than just this one show so it's greatly
appreciated but don't forget to smash
that like button subscribe to this
Channel and also go to the store
actually in the chat you can see there's
a pinned shirt the step on Snapchat or
go to timcast.com click the store and
get your step-on snack and find out
t-shirt look at that cute little guy
he's angry and he says don't you step on
on me and then of course we have our
visit Howard Springs totally voluntary
relocation camp and Australia poster and
T-shirt If you want to get those that
also helps support our work but let's
jump in to that first big story ladies
and gentlemen the most Draconian
lockdown we have seen yet from NBC New
York NYC expands vaccine mandate to hold
private sector UPS dose proof to two and
adds kids 5 to 11. Mayor Bill de Blasio
announced the expansion Monday amid yet
another coveted surge driving case rates
up across the five boroughs all private
sector workers in New York will be
subject to the mayor's vaccine mandate
starting December 27th affecting 184 000
businesses well vaccine proof for indoor
dining Fitness and entertainment will be
required for children ages 5 to 11
according to a toughened vaccine mandate
announced by Bill de Blasio on Monday
the current rule will also expand the
required two-dose required to two doses
instead of proof of only one as for
people age 12 and older Arkansas as they
are are concerned the mayor said that
excludes people who were vaccinated with
Johnson and Johnson's single dose shot
which is interesting kids aged 5 to 11
only needed to show proof of one dose
when the requirement for them kicks in
on December 14th considering they only
first became eligible for the initial
dose early in November and must wait at
least 21 days de Blasio did late last
week the changes to these policies blah
blah blah and I wonder if they're going
to make the kids present their
identification now what this mandate
means is that 30 I believe the number is
30.9 percent of New York State residents
will not be able to use these public
accommodations in New York City I don't
know what the full vax rate is for the
city but that's the state and Nationwide
this means 40 point I believe what is it
40.1 percent of American citizens will
not be able to go to New York City as
tourists and use any of these public
accommodations so this is outright
setting up restrictions controls may as
well put up borders and checkpoints
around the city because they're
basically saying a certain segment of
the country will not be welcome in this
place and you know what the people who
are not vaccinated most likely we know
this actually most of them are from the
black community and then I would imagine
many of the others are more likely to be
moderate or conservative those people
will likely leave and New York City will
just become a ridiculous mass of Deep
Blue Progressive leftist whatever yeah I
think this time it's going to work
though
this this lock this measure will bring
down the cases in the city and so you
know what let's just give it a couple
weeks and exactly are they still
vaccinating for the Delta variant
even though now there's a new variant
out I don't think they were ever
actually vaccinating for a specific area
they were just saying just go get the
vaccine and it's for the original the OG
yeah we should call this what this is
this is discrimination this is
segregation of populations this is only
going to further the political divide
further people moving out of New York
City and the mayor really used very
interesting language to to kind of
describe what he's doing he said that
this is a quote preemptive strike which
is very fitting for him to do that
because a preemptive start strike is
when you attack people and kill them
preemptively before doing anything else
that was that wasn't my words that was
literally Bill de Blasio saying
introducing this policy saying we need
to do this because of omnicron omnicrons
here we have to do this even though but
all the initial reports are saying that
people who have omnicrama the people who
are vaccinated so oh well I don't know
about that but they're saying it's
definitely mild and I think even fauci
brought that out but but also he's going
to be mandating small business owners
all businesses in New York are going to
have to do this and so we got this
report out of the Daily Mail these
businesses are saying we are going to
lose employees so a battered economy
people are already struggling and Bill
de Blasio look I said it before I'll say
it again I believe he intentionally is
trying to destroy the city and people
say that's a bold claim to him why would
he do that because in the past Bill de
Blasio said we are going to buy up these
buildings for pennies on the dollar and
convert them to public housing so there
you go there's his motive there's his
intent when you've got a guy who's like
my intention is to buy cheap property
that's big and we can turn to public
housing and then all of a sudden he
starts implementing policy after policy
by decree that destroys property value
I'm like what is this RoboCop wrote what
other movies we have the big bad guy
being like I'll destroy property values
and buy enough was not the Lego movie
also yeah
Mr Boss or whatever his name is that
what he was doing my question here and
and it's it's it's at the 30 000 foot
level at what point does an elected
Democrat say I don't have the authority
to do that right like what he's doing in
New York Biden said the last week or
maybe over the weekend I'm going to
mandate that the health insurance
companies pay for this new test and the
insurance companies must have been like
does he have the authority to do that
like it amazes me that elected Democrat
leaders there they never look at it as
an issue or a situation and say oh
that's above my authority level
everything they want to do they feel
that they have the right to do you're
making me want to run for office as a
Democrat yeah because you know no no not
for like any reason to be like I'm going
to buy buildings I'd just be like
um if you work in the automotive
industry then you have to bring me uh
one of those Belgian waffles yes have
you ever had those things waffles and
Dingus in New York those carts that are
all over the place that you know what
speculus is no cookie butter cookie
butter it's those Biscoff cookies they
pulverize it into a paste okay smear it
on a sugar waffle with whipped cream and
I'd be like oh you got to do it and then
what's gonna happen they're gonna back
I'm not doing that mandate it's mandated
I mean clearly what they're doing is
unconstitutional and this is already
ruled by the courts numerous times as it
pertains to Joe Biden now you so so Joe
Biden's like I hereby decree federal
workers have to do this and then
multiple courts are like no no and the
private sector uh lawsuits are already
going through and the Republicans are
saying they're going to vote this down
through their um special power that the
Senate has to challenge an executive
order we know Joe Biden is pushing the
boundaries we know that he's crossed the
line but Bill de Blasio is still doing
the same thing so I'll just put it this
way I think you know we need we need
someone to run for office as a Democrat
make all the promises in the world and
then just go nuts and decree the most
ludicrous things and you see like what
sticks like uh I you got to bring me uh
you gotta tithe to the to the City Hall
otherwise you know we'll uh send the
cops and the cops will do it oh yeah
we'll send the cops shut down your
business yeah you could you could you as
the mayor he could probably walk up to a
business and be like give me 50 bucks
yeah and they'd be like okay they do it
it's called taxes and it's more than
just 50 bucks no but I mean I mean like
he could literally just be like it's for
me I want to go to a strip club I mean
look at those old photos of New York in
the 30s and 40s and everyone's wearing a
hat I would make everyone in New York
has to wear a hat outside I have to wear
a hat perfect yes why not I have the
authority to do whatever I want it is
for your own good and if you can
determine any policy because it's for
the good of people whether it's their
health well I think aesthetic is very
very healthy as well y'all think we're
joking at home but uh they actually they
actually shut down churches and mosques
and synagogues and they went to the
Jewish neighborhood and shut down
schools they sh they well they they
chained uh Parks shut so that the the
Jewish Community couldn't have access to
these things yo if we have a a
politician who's outright like you know
that uh that what's the amendment where
you're allowed to have to speak and
practice your religion oh that's the
first amendment yeah yeah that one yeah
it's done shut down the churches and
then even the courts were like well
we're gonna allow this and then no one
did anything that person will become the
new CEO of Twitter yes you know if you
if you have that philosophy that's how
you get a that's how you get a promotion
if we're at the point where these
Democrats have literally just openly and
assuredly and confidently violated the
Constitution and the police said okay
yo man I'm sorry if I'm a little
pessimistic sometimes but right there no
one where were the people in New York to
be like we're not doing this I mean
there were a lot of people who did but
certainly not enough and it was a year
ago and you can all see the footage
online at New Year's Eve where de Blasio
and his wife danced in Times Square and
all of New York was shut down they
weren't allowed to go to the Times
Square there was no ball drop but he was
there with his wife dancing because he
was the mayor and he was allowed and he
wasn't masked and that was a year ago
and we've been through a year of this BS
that we're still playing all of these
games of these lockdown and it was a
year ago The French Laundry a year ago
Nancy Pelosi got her hair done
Gretchen Whitmer and Michigan got her
hair done and she also shut down
famously a barber in a small town that
had no coven yeah it's a it's the
perfect example these people are I mean
look de Blasio dancing in Times Square
after he mandated everyone be kicked out
and no one cares no I mean I'm sure I'm
sure a lot of people care but not enough
to be like hey this guy's bad I don't
know Obama had a huge birthday party
which was supposed to be limited in
number and had hundreds of celebrities
coming from all around the world flying
on their private jets to celebrate this
as the corporate media was literally
making excuses saying that the
sophisticated crowd don't have to follow
the specific rules and regulations that
everyone else does that's pretty much
what they're trying to establish here
and they've been doing it pretty
successfully because when you look at
these kind of decrees and I call them
decrees these mandates these supposed
laws they're not laws they're just
literally politicians saying I'm gonna
play God for a day when you look at who
these decrees affect it's small and
middle class businesses because as they
can't afford to now hire a security
guard to check everyone's paper they
can't afford to keep employees on the
payroll especially with a labor shortage
that's it that's absolutely eviscerating
and destroying their livelihoods and
ability to even have a business who can
be okay with these businesses with these
regulations with these rules with these
decrees Amazon Walmart CVS Duane Reade
they could afford a loss here as
everyone else gets eviscerated so this
is not only perpetuating the larger
transfer of wealth and recorded human
history this is also accelerating the
political segregation that's forcing a
lot of people in New York City I used to
live in New York City before covid to
move out and say you know what I'm going
to vote with my dollar I'm going to vote
with my feet I'm going to go to New
Hampshire I'm going to go to New West
Virginia I'm going to go to Florida I'm
going to go somewhere where I'm
respected where I have freedom where I
have Liberty where I have sovereignty
where I am a human being and I could
actually live my life without a Jack
boot Thug officer looking over my
shoulder demanding my paperwork
identification with every little thing I
do what's happening in Europe right now
people are having dinners police
officers coming over them saying give me
your paperwork right now or we're going
to punish you or we're going to steal
more money from you or we're going to
beat the crap out of you or we're going
to put you in jail is absolutely insane
and it's it's a violation of Human
Rights I would argue it's actually a bit
worse in New York City because the
people who are enforcing this are the
citizens
you know in in you looked at Germany you
guys see that that video of the Germans
during the military uh March and they
all kind of torches yeah at the same
time this story comes out where Germany
is marching with torches there's a story
out of Germany where it's like far-right
marches of torches and are condemned for
like for using them it's like sure okay
whatever but in New York you look into
Germany and you look to Austria and you
know who the Nazis are you see the video
out of Austria where the cops walk up to
a random guy in the mall and they're
like give us your papers and he pulls
out his papers but in New York it's the
people themselves and this is one of the
clever there's a very clever thing done
by the Democratic establishment and the
people in New York that they're like
where we're having this and our
enforcers will be you you snitching on
your neighbor so when you walk into the
restaurant it's the people who work
there who say no no you have to do this
otherwise we'll get in trouble yeah so
it's not the police
I mean there are many police but it's
regular people and so when I was talking
about this many times I'm like they're
the Nazis
the people the small business owners
these people who are willing to sell out
all of their values and fall in line for
draconian unconstitutional edict from an
executive
that's the problem it's the finale of
evil them just being like it's mundane
it's normal I must ask a five-year-old
for his ID otherwise he can't come in
this hungry man I'm sorry you don't get
access to public accommodations because
of your medical condition or otherwise
have a nice day yeah you know what's
fascinating is where New York is
protecting the Integrity of their Health
Care system by mandating these uh um
requirements and the identification that
you are compliant with the requirement
but when it comes to the Integrity of
their elections if you proposed an ID
system they would oh it's laughable
absolutely a five-year-old has to have
his ID now what five-year-old has an ID
exactly what five-year-old has a
driver's license what what id do you
have for a five-year-old exactly and
quite frankly if I had a five-year-old
and they were like we want to take his
picture for an idea I'd be like listen
creepy Jeffrey Epstein person I don't
know who you are taking a photo of my
five-year-old but we don't he doesn't
need a fight an ID you get that they'll
probably say no no that's crazy you
don't need an ID for this just your vax
card well the vax card is effectively a
form of identification but they've
always said that but no no every place
in New York City that does these and
they're becoming more rarer by the day
you need to show your identification
with your vast card so that people could
validate that it's your vax card how
else can you validate that it's
someone's vax card if you don't have a
proper form of identification you've
mentioned small businesses in New York
and I've been born and raised in New
York City and my whole family is
basically still in New York City and you
you talk about living there like you go
to a deli or a pizzeria the guy who owns
it makes the pizza does the cash
register if you have to add on top of
his responsibilities can I see your vax
card before I I just what do you want to
slice a slice and a coke 225 let's go
next like yeah you know so now on top of
this I have to also
check your status like I don't have time
to do that I'm trying to run a business
so you bring up I just want to get
something to eat let's talk about this
next story where a woman was effectively
starved by the Canadian government woman
goes 40 hours without eating in Trudeau
quarantine facility that's intense so I
I recently I did a fast over uh over a
day during the holidays because actually
the day before we're gonna have our
Thanksgiving dinner I'm like I am not
eating today and then tomorrow I am
going to have Thanksgiving and uh
fasting's not easy I wouldn't say it's
like the hardest thing in the world but
40 hours basically two days because you
know she's gonna sleep she's probably
gonna get some food before batter
hopefully woman goes 48 hours without
eating a woman with an extreme Celiac
eating disease has told media she did
not eat any food for 40 hours in
Trudeau's quarantine facility let me let
me tell you know the quarantine facility
is it's an internment camp and it's I
it's it's the definitions get murky but
James Lindsay had an excellent tweet
from the Holocaust Museum explaining
what a concentration camp is it is a
facility that detains people without due
process
interesting they said what separates
from concentration camps from normal
prisons is that there is no due process
and you are taken without any chance to
defend yourself go to trial anything
like that so it is different if you fly
in somewhere and you know by going here
you will be subject to this what's going
on in Australia is very different
they're going to people's homes and
taking them without due process now they
say this woman from Edmonton Alberta she
had to stay in quarantine uh quarantino
Hotel in Toronto after flying back from
Ethiopia the woman did not eat as the
facility did not provide her with
gluten-free food celiacs can become
seriously unwell if they break their
strict diet the woman and her husband
had to quarantine until they received a
negative test result as they had been to
South Africa recently this despite the
fact that her husband had three Doses
and she had two they were quarantined at
the Hilton Hotel the one said she had to
be careful with the food sheets so I
I've known people with celiacs who get
like sick to the point of
hospitalization if they eat gluten it's
like they have it's like an allergy I
don't know if it's if if allergy and
sealants are not the same thing are they
no I don't think so Celiac is an
autoimmune disease which a lot of my
family has because for some odd reason
it's very common in Irish women huh
really I'm lucky yes I have a lot of
female cousins who have Celiac so it's
not an allergy it's an autoimmune
disease I think I think my friend had an
allergy and they were like legit can't
eat it get sick swelling potential
anaphylaxis and stuff like that and you
know you take it seriously so if you're
being forced into quarantine but they're
not providing proper accommodation this
is just I'll put it this way there's a
big difference like I said if you choose
to fly into a place where you know
they're doing this that being said I
think I still think it's a violation of
human rights to Bar people from
traveling with this coercive method
basically what they're saying is like
when when they initially launched the
sink I think Australia and Canada were
like it's two thousand dollars if you
fly in you've got to pay for the
quarantine and so that's basically
saying sorry people only if you're rich
so I think we're at a point where
it feels to me like everything they're
doing is a coercive measure to just push
people down they don't give you the
right food there's videos of people and
they take photos of their food and one
guy was like here's what I was given
it's one slice of bologna on two pieces
of white bread in a quarantine and now
you have in Australia they're upping it
to taking you from your home randomly
without you traveling yeah well it's
incremental first it's it's just going
to be two weeks to slow the spreads then
it's just wear the mask just take this
vaccine just take a second vaccine a
third vaccine a fourth vaccine oh you
want to travel somewhere you can only do
it if you're rich if you're established
and this isn't the first Horror Story
from one of these quarantined facilities
quarantine facilities there was multiple
stories of women getting assaulted
there's multiple stories of security
guards literally going into the rooms
which they have to keep open for
security guards security guards having
their way uh with people again family
friendly shows and we're not going to go
too into the details here but
absolutely disgusting things have
happened all in the name of government
looking out for your Safety and Security
and they're not doing any of those
they're this is a larger power grab this
is all about acquiescence this is all
about slowly pushing you to comply with
a bigger and bigger and bigger request
and it's only going to get worse from
here in my opinion yeah I think the
message take away if it's possible is
what we saw with a lot of the Biden
mandates when people just said I'm not
going to comply and then the courts
ruled in our favor and said yeah this is
a total violation hopefully New Yorkers
it's going to take one one small
business to be the first one to say you
know what we're not checking IDs
and then another will follow it another
will follow but that first person to
take that risk though is well they've
it's happened yeah and they have to do
more of it there was a deli and then
this one guy went around with Flyers
handing them out and they started
putting open windows that bar in Staten
Island also that guy was pretty famous I
forget his name there was a bar in
Staten Island who refused to shut down
and he had been the gym in New Jersey
those guys are on TV quite a lot well I
was in New York City a couple days ago
and no one's enforcing anything
no one is asking people to wear masks no
one asked me for my identifications or
vaccine papers I went around some people
are complying some people aren't but
businesses especially if you run a
business in New York City you know you
can't do everything so to enforce this
ridiculous decree where everyone has to
give up their their ID and medical
records just to go into a store I mean
even the people who do comply aren't for
this because people forget their papers
they lose their papers they lose their
documents their their whole
identification system is on a piece of
paper that literally anyone could print
out which the federal authorities have
made illegal to do so but but well using
the seat using federal government logos
or anything like that exactly so well
right now in Florida I think it's Advent
medical Network big hospital announced
they've suspended their vaccine mandate
because the courts have ruled
unconstitutional or they've effectively
Frozen it so the interesting thing is I
think this was Biden's strategy all
along I think the strategy that we're
seeing from these uh from these
governments is tell people you have to
do it and then cross their fingers that
people will do it before they realize
the government has no authority to do
this so Biden's like we're going to
mandate this you know it's done and it's
like that was a press conference there's
no decree there's no executive order but
then businesses come out and they just
say well you know Biden said we have to
so everyone go do it by this date or
else much people then say okay then they
come back and say oh you know what they
just said we don't have to do it so you
don't have to do it if that were me if I
worked for a company I'd file a lawsuit
against the company yeah you'd be like
hold on Joe Biden never issued the
decree Joe Biden never
formalize the executive order
OSHA eventually put the rule and it was
suspended but before then a lot of
companies like Airlines were like well
Joe Biden said federal workers and
contractors have to have it I would then
say the company lied use it as an excuse
decreed we get an irreversible medical
procedure I could never take that back
I'm suing
and it's it's not just New York City
that I experienced a lot of people just
not complying not going along with this
nonsense it's also being reported in
Ottawa that by and large their vaccine
mandate has failed because of the labor
shortages and businesses not being able
to be open because of these strict rules
and regulations that they have on people
and another aspect of these mandates
that we have to understand here they're
they're cruel and unusual because also
of the larger question of liability so
if if I get hurt and I get forced to
take this vaccine who's liable I am I'm
paying the medical bills the person who
forced you to do this the government
that forced you to do this the Pharma
that created this product they're not
liable for anything that happens to you
if you are hurt or injured during the
process of this uh you know vaccine so
that's another aspect of it that people
need to understand and you know a lot of
people are asking the very basic
question you know you really want me to
take this why don't you take some
liability on yourself so there's stories
of people coming forward and saying look
I'll print a liability form you just
again guarantee liability for yourself
if you're forcing me to do this and many
businesses are like okay
I told people if you work for a company
that says we're doing a vax mandate show
up the next day and be like I think it's
wonderful you're doing this absolutely
now this is a liability waiver saying
that you as an employer are requiring
this for me and you assume all risks
associated with the medical procedure
see what they say and if they say no I'd
be like that's really interesting why
you don't think it's safe and then if
they say well why why do you want us to
sign this and be like well because
you're requiring it like if I told if I
told you I required you to drive a car
and then you crash the car who's
responsible for it like the business
like if I if I was driving a pizza a
pizza truck for for a company and then I
get and someone hits me that's injury
out in the workplace right so they deal
with it what's what's the matter boss
you think it's unsafe sign it but guess
what a lot of businesses probably will
be like sure and they will and then hey
there you go yeah for the rest of your
life you're you're identified they
assumed all responsibility and then you
got it included it to something like in
the event of the dissolution of the
business the live ability folds over to
the company's owners and principal
officers Etc et cetera and then see how
fast they say I can't sign that and be
like oh you want you wanted me to assume
the liability for this medical procedure
that's a weird thing to ask maybe you've
got some great lawyer who's listening to
the podcast right now who can make those
readily available online they are
available online and people have them
available
stories of people printing this out and
saying you know you want me to get this
name here I will but you take liability
and you take responsibility for forcing
this medical procedure on me that might
uh cause me some problems and then and
then here's what else you do if they say
no to that you have a backup and say oh
okay well the next one says that you are
refusing to assume the requirement
liability the liabilities for
requirement of the vaccine and thus will
not be punishing me because you decided
you didn't want to uh sign this form so
yeah I mean you can do clever things you
could say like the liability waiver is
actually a like a request form like this
is the document saying that you are
hereby requesting I get the vaccine for
continued employment and then you know
it also includes Assumption of liability
and all the standard legal stuff for
your request and then if they say whoa
whoa I don't I don't want to assign that
you can be like well if you refuse to
sign the document saying you require me
to get the vaccine sign this one saying
you are hereby exempting me from the
vaccine they gotta sign one of them yeah
go back oh no I I won't sign either he's
got to do it like oh then sign the one
since I got to do it yeah or just
respecting people's exemptions there's
people who literally can't take the
vaccine because of allergies because of
previous medical conditions because of
religious beliefs you have to respect
people's individuals beliefs I mean and
their own individual medical history we
get it but we're so far beyond that at
this point you know like how long has it
been since it's been months you know I
had a Fox News Van pulls up and they're
like hop on Tim and it was I was like
they just decreed the Mandate for the
first time in New York and there's no
medical exemptions and I I look back at
that interview which like apparently got
picked up and I was like that was a
stupid argument I was like how dare they
mandate this with no medical exemptions
and I'm just like and I'm just like how
how do they mandate this period
regardless but we I feel like it's just
I don't know what else to say other than
hey this keeps happening it's gonna keep
happening and it's going to be escalated
they're going to turn up the heat so I
don't know what I'll tell you other than
get out of cities because people in New
York keep voting for the same thing and
so long as you've got people living in
The Matrix and you don't want to live
there well you got to choose take the
blue already I would say New York City
is copying Europe's homework Europe is
copying Australia's homework and that's
the plan that they literally have
envisioned for everyone in particular
stages they just call it different names
but essentially when you see the larger
implication of this social credit score
police state that they're putting on to
everyone it's happening in different
layers in different stages New York City
is going where Europe is and in Europe
it's it's going to such an insane level
where Italy just joined Austria and
Germany with their new lockdowns against
the unvaccinated people and they just
implemented their super green pass but
Austria is literally putting forward a
decree that by February 15th people have
to be vaccinated or faced penalties from
the state which may include fines or
jail time for not taking a vaccine which
means if you're at home you don't even
go outside you're on you're on lockdown
because of the government you still will
be punished for sitting at home in
isolation by yourself the government is
making legalese language exempt from the
Nuremberg code to literally force their
way into your life even if you don't
participate in society the Nuremberg
code thing is is hyperbole it's people
who don't understand what it says a
bunch like like even the post-millennial
put out an article saying that you know
European Union Chiefs wants to do what
the European Nuremberg coach he never
said that she didn't say that but
they're implying because she said that
we should maybe have a vaccine mandate
she didn't even say we should she didn't
say we're gonna do this she said maybe
there's something European countries
should do and then someone took that and
said well that would violate the
Nuremberg code because the Nuremberg
code says to participate in experiment
requires consent and so I'm like okay
y'all are playing semantic manipulation
break this down properly because here's
what's going to happen you're going to
get someone who's going to see that
story from the post millennial and I
like them you know we're fans of Libby
Libby Emmons but they're going to be at
a family gathering whatever they're
going to say the the the the chief
European Union lady said she wants to
get rid of the Nuremberg code now and
then they're gonna pull up on Google and
be like she literally never said
anything of the sort she said she wanted
to start a conversation about mandating
vaccines throughout all the European
Union which is the conversation which
then if you start from there and talk
about what to what degree the vaccine is
experimental so you know the argument is
that because there's no long-term
testing and because they don't have uh
the insert says like we don't know the
risks to pregnant women people are
arguing well that means it is
experimental and it's like sure there's
a big difference between saying we're
going to force someone to drink vodka
and Watch Ratatouille you know because
that's like some of the experiments they
do at these universities that's actually
that's actually one of them the ones I
did they gave me vodka and then I
watched I think I watched Ratatouille
that's a great movie and they wanted to
see like you know I did an aptitude like
a general you know quiz at the end of it
but that's experimentation the Nuremberg
code specifically is like if we're going
to uh bring you to a lab and do studies
on you you have to consent to it yeah to
say that someone is getting an emergency
vaccine and that's violating the number
of code is live well you could get your
lawyers in there and make that argument
but we all I'm saying is call it
whatever you want make sure your
language is precise otherwise you're
going to lose the argument well they're
not getting it they're being coerced
into getting it and manipulated into
getting it by government uh taking away
their their access to society
I'm just saying you know people are are
taught are talking about the Nuremberg
without actually having looking into the
source material and you will lose
arguments you will not convince anybody
by being hyperbolic but can we just back
up and recognize the fact that like
Italy and Germany are making an alliance
not like raise anymore
not only that but German soldiers are
literally marching around with Tiki tiki
torches honoring their leader Angela
Merkel as a 150 major German
corporations just announced that they're
going to conduct the largest vaccination
promotion effort ever literally
regurgitating the government's talking
points trying to impose their will on
the people of Germany so there's a lot
of history let's pull this up we got
this story from the local.de this is a
German news source explained why is
German Twitter up in arms over a
Torchlight military parade uh it's not
so much that a bunch of you know German
you know military men of some some
degree are Marching through the night
with torches it's that Germany is also
implementing la Downs for the
unvaccinated we're seeing in Australia
now this outside of Germany the
internment camps where you will be taken
from your home with no due process and
then detained in a little tiny box where
they tell you you can only go outside to
do your laundry you can't or you have a
balcony sorry but you can't cross the
line you'll be fine five thousand
dollars
so Germany as Daniel just mentioned
Italy Austria all coming together and
being like we are going to mandate this
injection upon the populace otherwise
you can't have food
and now they're marching around with
torches does their Camp have a little
signup over that says like the vi like
the the vaccine sets you free or
something like that yeah
those are the arguments that that
government bureaucrats have been making
take this vaccine do as you're told and
you're gonna gain your freedom freedoms
back you're gonna gain your access to
society back you're going to be able to
go to a restaurant and purchase food
well even Biden is hinted at that you
know yeah more than hinted at it he said
that as much and that's such a backwards
did our same kind of critical way of
thinking that we have to we have to
first understand on face value they're
the ones who took away normal life
they're the ones who take took away
economic Prosperity they're the ones who
took away our ability to live a normal
prosperous happy healthy life they're
the ones literally implementing policies
that have created more Depression more
suicide lack of economic opportunities
have impoverished people and literally
have stolen their wealth right in front
of them literally disappearing the value
of their dollar as it sits in their
hands the value that the value of the
dollar be is being extremely devalued
and and people are finding that less and
less they have the ability to do
anything that they want and every aspect
of their existence is being tightly
regulated and controlled by bureaucrats
who think they're Gods the funny thing
is this this uh is actually an old story
it's from October the German torch story
what was the what were they marching
about though that is kind of weird to
happen no they're celebrating Angela
Merkel and this was a payover they were
marching to uh honor those who risked
their lives or lost their lives in their
operations in Afghanistan as part of the
withdrawal and so this is back in
October this story at least I don't know
maybe they did it again for Angela
Merkel but this is the story on on the
local and the funny thing is they're
march marching next to the reichstag is
how do you pronounce it yes with torches
in their hands so the funny thing is
when they announced that they were going
to be locking down anybody who didn't
get the the the uh the vaccine a lot of
people were like oh there's Germany
getting back to tradition and getting
back to their roots of you know mandated
medical procedures and then this photo
is actually old and people are like hey
maybe something's been going on in
Germany that we haven't been paying
attention to uh there was a joke I can't
remember who did it
um do you maybe when you guys remember
he was like
who was this who was I saw this recently
um hold on I'm trying to think I can't
remember he said that uh if if he were
like the uni whatever after World War II
you know who this was maybe he was like
we'd tell Germany you don't get to be a
country anymore it's like you started a
war against the world like literally
trying to Norm Macdonald maybe yeah I
think it was not McDonald's he was like
you started a war against the world yeah
so uh you don't get to be a country
anymore because look what happens when
we just like let them keep doing their
things it's a weird thing but you know
if you don't have you know what I love
the most about the European Union in
Germany is that we literally have like
two Wars in a cold war in an attempt to
prevent the the consolidation of power
in Europe under one governing Authority
and then Germany comes along and they're
like hey guys let's do this Union thing
we'll have the strongest economy your
currencies will all be devalued and then
you have to borrow from US and Germany
basically becomes the dominant power in
the European Union amazing I have a
pretty lit friend on the right who I
won't say his name but who has a whole
theory that Germany is the worst country
in the history of civilization because
starting when he's he's very very
Catholic uh starting with Martin Luther
in the Reformation oh yeah and he goes
through every every 1500 years something
has come from a manual [ __ ] something
comes out of Germany that is destructive
to the rest of the western values ending
with world ending with the green
movement in Germany he's like I have
evidence that Germany's no offense to
any of your German listeners
um I mean Germany is the worst country
in the history of of the western
civilization it's a pretty funny theory
was communism coming out of uh Germany
Carl where was Karl Marx from what are
you from Austria yeah yeah was it was it
I thought it was German the Frankfurt
School was that from Frankfurt I don't
want to be you know yeah a little dull I
don't know I don't know where they say
it's the Frankfurt School is that is the
answer that obvious sure bring for
Germany Karl Marxist yeah Marx was
German yeah what are these guys doing
exactly now Beethoven was also German
this is the funny you love him very much
this is the funniest thing about like
white nationalists and like their views
I'm like yo like these bad ideas
literally came from Germany dude like
you guys were just full of bad ideas oh
I I I I think the white nationalists you
know don't identify with the Communists
but I'm like yo
you guys you need to rethink ideology
because you have no idea what you're
talking about because you just sound
really dumb when we look at Germany and
like hey all the bad stuff like the
extremist ideologies of of that era
mostly came from like these places yeah
yeah we want freedom you know the people
who came to the the Americas were just
kind of like yo we want to do our thing
even if it means like Landing a boat on
a Barren Shore in the woods and just
building right there and like these
people would get on these boats and
they'd be like well one-fifth of these
the people on these boats are gonna die
before we even make it there and then
once we do another half will die before
winter comes let's hope we have enough
water you know don't run out of apples
how long are we gonna be on the boat I
don't know four months three months
depends upon the wind yeah they have to
bring like limes with them how did they
pull that off did everyone just have
scurvy and they're all like hunched over
when they arrive I can't imagine the
folks who did it for back and forth
full-time the Traders right hence the
Dutchy Dutch East India Company be being
I think still to this day consider the
most wealthy company in the history of
the world yeah but imagine going across
season you do it again you come back you
go back holy cow the amazing thing about
it was how many people they killed over
making food taste better yeah it's like
dude sometimes like when I have steak we
just do a little salt on it I guess but
man they were ready to like colonize
invade destroy burn pillage murder and
you know enslave did I say that all
because they were like food must taste
better cinnamon pepper saffron black
peppercorn man that was it minus my
understanding is that black peppercorn
was like they would they would stab you
conquer the world sprinkle it on their
food I admit black pepper tastes good
but now everyone's got it on every Diner
table yeah we are very lucky we are very
privileged and that privilege and that
luck is slowly being taken away from us
by you know a Sinister group of really
bad billionaire corporatists but you
know throughout history when when you
look at history they they not only tell
very interesting Tales but one common
thread is is always these crazy
megalomaniac people trying to rule the
entire world trying to take over the
entire world whether it was Caesar
Napoleon Genghis Khan Alexander the
Great Hillary Clinton Attila the Hun
Vlad the Impaler there was always a
group of of of of of people that wanted
the entire world for themselves and I
think it would be naive to think that
there isn't another kind of person or
group that wants to do that today and I
think a lot of the crazy policies that
violate human rights are their way of
doing it of slowly incrementally putting
it on us without us noticing that there
is someone trying to have control of
everything there's of course competing
interests of very powerful individuals
who want control of a lot of things
that's just history like you were
mentioning but I think back to the movie
The Patriot because I love that movie so
much when um and you guys have seen that
with Mel Gibson sure he's meeting with I
think Cornwallis and they're discussing
discussing you know officer exchange or
whatever and it's like a trick or
something but he but the Cornwallis is
like we're going to discuss you the the
cease the cessation of the targeting of
officers on the field and he was like
gladly when your officer stopped
targeting children and then apparently
that scene like the British got really
mad like the actual British were like
we've never done that that didn't happen
but anyway I digress the the point was
in that film they make the point that
during war they'd be like okay we're all
gonna go out and March and kill each
other but spare the officers and
cornwalls was like could you imagine
what battlefields would be like without
gentlemen in charge it would be chaos
this is the same attitude it persists
today the ultra wealthy Elites are like
oh we'll go to war but don't worry if
you lose you're fine you know we'll
we'll we'll take care of you going to
Exile whatever we'll just kill all of
your all of your civilians and citizens
and then you as the wealthy and Powerful
Elite for the most part you're spared
except when it comes to more Modern
Warfare now it's like if you defy the
established order like they'll invade
your country and they'll just burn
everything to the ground like Hillary
Clinton we came we saw he died now it's
gotten like just very straightforward
War Death murder Etc oh or they'll all
their like or they will cancel you
that's also another way and I think the
more we're moving from Modern Warfare
we're moving into a different form where
I think it's psychological I think
people inflicting harm on themselves
after being brainwashed into
propagandized is an aspect of this that
we should be entertaining because if you
look at the the kind of biggest increase
in cause of death suicide and debts of
Despair becoming more and more common
and they're growing every single day so
I wouldn't be surprised if that's
another layer another aspect of fourth
generational Warfare or some people some
people would say fifth generational
Warfare I think we have to entertain all
of those aspects especially because this
concept of one person bombing and
attacking and conquering another place
has failed throughout human history and
I think there's powerful people who are
a lot smarter than that and they have
started to implement it in a different
way where it's not really that obvious
because if it was too many people would
resist them just like in recorded human
history they resisted them and they
weren't able to fully successfully take
over well let's let's talk about La
Resistance we have this story from the
post to Millennial Trump's New Media
platform and Rumble have distribution
deal there is a lot of good to discuss
here there's also a decent amount of bad
and concern and the notable thing here
is they say Howard lutnik the CEO of
rumble's parent company Cantor
Fitzgerald stated on Monday that they
have worked at a distribution deal with
Donald Trump's planned truth social
media platforms I want to say right now
when they say that the CEO of rumble's
parent company is Canter Fitzgerald that
means Rumble is now a subsidiary of
institutional Wall Street investment
firms that are one of 24 uh investment
firms that can do direct dealings with
the Federal Reserve so this does not
sound to me like an independent free
safe place to run your business it
sounds just like they're building the B
side to Big Tech however that being said
you were saying earlier this lutnik guy
was like a big Trump supporter yes the
the CEO of Kenneth Fitzgerald is
um I totally get your point
um but there's good news here that's why
I bring it there is good news I mean we
do need Alternatives and I think a
plurality of voices is the way to go
um but yeah I share your concern that if
it's just owned by another Wall Street
company who is going to have to follow
SEC regulations and SEC regulations
under this Administration could be
unless 75 percent of the board of all of
your subsidiaries are made up of people
who we agree with their political
persuasion then you can't get your uh
uh you know you can trade on you can't
trade on the big board there's a
possibility here that this is a massive
concerted effort among powerful
interests to counter the woke
establishment big Tech because Rumble
getting this access and getting this
investment getting this power could be a
good thing if you believe in the stuff I
think the bigger risk is you know Ian
mentioned this as soon as they opened as
soon as they go public with the they did
a spec a special purpose acquisition
company Rumble opens the door to
Vanguard was it State Street BlackRock
buying up percentage of the company and
then putting pressure on them and then
they're basically just Google again so
it's almost like there's a fear of a
controlled opposition if the company
remained private we have more reason to
believe that they'll actually stick to
their principles and not censor and ban
people but let's read a little bit of
the news here first and then we'll get
into the the tech stuff truth and the
45th president are going to use rumbles
infrastructure the technology their
Cloud distribution capability so they
are going to be a service provider a
tech provider to the president's truth
social Lut next told interviewer John
Bachmann on his John Bachmann now show
for something they got Joe Rogan here
for some reason Rumble a video based Pro
Feast Pro free speech platform Works in
a similar manner to other streaming
services and full disclosure we here at
timcast we use Rumble infrastructure and
we are more confident we won't get
banned there but that being said we'll
speak honestly lutnik continue during
the interview what this is is people
with political ideology being asked to
leave YouTube comedians are now coming
over gamers are coming over it's a broad
group of people uh who don't want to be
censored they want to be able to speak
their mind speak their truths and speak
their opinions so I think Rumble which
is neutral down the middle I think it's
going to get a huge following of people
who just want to speak their minds
lutnik further iterated that Rumble
after this the deal struck with the
struck with this company will now have
the money to now go do whatever they
want to do I mean that's that's
potentially good news right right off
the bat this means that all the people
who are worried about not having a way
to compete with YouTube's infrastructure
can now go somewhere else and there's
going to be Revenue there what Rumble
needs to do right now is they need to
use as much money as they can to create
a comparable partner program that
YouTube has because the number one thing
that keeps people from leaving this
platform is audience size but more
importantly for newer creators and new
Talent it's the fact that YouTube is
subsidized by Google alphabet whatever
so you YouTube costs Google money
but they subsidize it so that people
stay on this platform
if Rumble can do the same thing and I
also think they do got to clean up their
interface and you know their website
needs a you know it's a little a little
messy then people are going to be like
look if I'm going to start a channel
somewhere why go on YouTube someone
who's making a new channel is going to
speak out and speak up against all this
you know this BS going on around the
world they're going to say if I go on
YouTube I'll get a strike right like
Elijah Shaffer and Sydney Watson friends
for instance on you are here they've
gotten how many strikes already like
takedown's a couple yeah already in the
show's new so there's gonna be a lot of
people being like I just do it on Rumble
I don't have you know people without big
followings without a ton of followers
will just be like I'll start a rumble
Channel and then at the very least I can
make money there the exact same way I
could make it on YouTube well it's funny
that the same article I assume this is
from today or the last couple days this
article axios is uh has a totally
different spin where I think the
headline is I should pull it up the
headline is something like the right
wing Echo chamber and it's funny it's
it's first of all to think that like the
left isn't just one Echo chamber right
like every single publication newspaper
TV Outlet is literally just saying the
exact same thing as the DNC and it's
insulting to call a nickel chamber
because it's not it's a platform
but it's just it's axios's spin we have
the article right here this is how the
media lies right
Wing builds its own Echo chamber is an
opinion and it's also incorrect it's a
false framing but for them to put this
on a news article it shows you the the
why we need alternative platforms it's
not an echo chamber be just because
different right-wing websites exist
doesn't mean people don't read other
news an echo chamber would be a cultural
phenomenon where people are like I'm not
going to watch any other news but we
know from the data conservatives get
about a third of their news from
mainstream liberal or leftist sources
whereas liberals get five percent so
what we're actually seeing here the news
is right-wing media emerges and it's not
even right wing it's independent
moderate libertarian and conservative
you know it's an echo chamber the
YouTube front page you go on that and
it's the same voices the same political
opinions regurgitate regurgitated to you
in in so many different uh formats I'm
skeptical news sorry whenever you swipe
to the left and you get to the news
thing look at Apple look at the top
stories on Apple news Echo chamber so
sorry same talking points same headlines
same kind of narrative nothing deviating
from of course the larger agenda that's
set against the American people but you
know I'm skeptical of Rumble but it's
going to be very interesting to see how
they're going to kind of Traverse this
online landscape where they're going to
go how they're going to be different or
if they're just going to be sellouts I'm
skeptical because of things like the ESG
the environmental social justice and
governments social credit score that a
lot of top companies have to be
compliant with and the more essentially
woke you are the more you sell out to
the agenda a narrative the better score
you have the more investment money you
have the more economic opportunities you
have the better evaluations you have so
this is a key indicator of of how it's
going to be playing out for many large
corporations so to see Rumble in this
system if it's going to be played by it
if it's going to be destroyed by it I I
think it's it's worth starting a
conversation about because it's going to
be very interesting to see if this is
just going to be another or sell out
major big tech company that that has a
bunch of people at the top who want to
make a bunch of money or if it's going
to be something that actually challenges
the status quo challenges the current
infrastructure that people have to fight
with that destroys free speech in the
First Amendment
I I think it's like chat this challenged
me the more the stronger you per the
push the more powerful I become yes
challenge me get bigger get stronger and
then I'll buy you well they have the One
Ring they're trying to defeat Sean with
another one ring the way I can do it I
can withstand the pressure of being a
bit having a billion dollar centralized
social network with proprietary no one
can withstand that man they're coming
with billions and billions of secs
coming and the government's coming like
it's not Chris's company anymore
rumble's gone it's not but I still think
this is a big net positive as much as I
don't think it's a permanent solution
they mentioned at post-millennial that
Trump's anti-big Tech social media
startup raised one billion dollars from
investors over the weekend to fund the
digital Venture quote one billion
dollars sends an important message to
big Tech that censorship and political
discrimination must end America is ready
for truth social a platform that will
not discriminate on the basis of
political ideology Trump stated this
will be this will be interesting because
look
I signed up for a rumble uh I'm sorry
not Rumble um parlor I am we are on
Rumble but I was I signed up for parlor
like okay okay this is like the 80th
time they've been like this is the
alternative and then Trump now I guess
is using the Mastodon code to launch his
own version yeah and they've
acknowledged that as of yesterday oh
okay well at any rate this is one I will
actually immediately sign up for I'll be
like okay you know I'll use this because
it's Donald Trump it's it's there's
there's there's power behind it and
there's going to be a big push from
everybody who wants to follow Donald
Trump to be on that platform that makes
it viable one of the things that makes
it really difficult for all these other
alternative platforms is are there
people there to talk to yeah YouTube's
got it Twitter's got it Facebook has it
but no one really cares about Facebook
for the most part now these Alternatives
they don't really have it that much even
Rumble does not really have it so what
they did was they got you know they paid
for people like like uh siraj has a show
there right and Glenn Greenwald and a
few other people were paid by Rumble to
do you know programming on their
platform because they need people
otherwise why would you go there all of
this stacking up
I actually think we might be saying what
I've long been asking for so I don't
want to rain on the parade you know when
it now that we're seeing this deal and
we're seeing this investment in this
infrastructure it looks like a lot of
free speech voices or at the very least
people who are mad about being censored
are being like if we don't do something
against big Tech we will lose and I've
been saying that over and over again
they think they can go in and say
section 230 reform and I'm like yo
you're sitting on fat stacks why don't
you just be like okay here's 10 million
dollars to fund this the initial
infrastructure get this going well now
there's a billion dollars and it was
raised by guess by investors buying
through the spec so all in all I think
it's pretty good news but of course but
of course well and we're going to get
into the important part here did you
think my friends it would be that easy
from CNBC Trump's back under
investigation by federal Regulators
including the SEC the SEC and finra
probes were disclosed by a filing by
Digital World acquisition Corp the
special purpose acquisition company on
track 2 merge with Trump media and
Technology Group they're already
fighting back the government is coming
after Trump and a social media platform
because I think it actually is a threat
to their established narrative BS
it's going to be it's going to be
interesting because Trump kind of plays
like he's a part of the establishment
and then kind of counters The
Establishment
um I obviously don't have a lot of Hope
in him personally myself after his
latest moves especially with some of the
interviews that he's been given on Fox
News recently uh Shilling for of course
big Pharma That's my kind of perspective
that's my understanding of it so to see
the government kind of hit him I think
it's more personal than it is anything
else and I think there's a bigger fight
here and we have to acknowledge that
fight is happening but I still see it as
One Wing of the same bird kind of
slapping each other at the end of the
day
um from my own perspective I think if
you are the social media platforms uh
look at what Zuckerberg did in the 2020
election through Facebook
and and how he I mean Molly Hemingway's
book on that is just absolutely
brilliant
um her book rigged and how Zuckerberg
spent his way into
flipping the election in key States for
for the Democrats
um they're not going to give up that
power pretty easily so I'm not surprised
that that the FEC is going after this
because on the SEC is going after it
because they don't want to lose their
power and the Biden Administration I
mean this is they use government uh
authoritatively whenever they get the
chance I mean that's the lesson they
learned from Obama also heck today also
Merrick Garland announced he's his uh
he's suing the state of Texas again
because of their redistricting because
they don't want the districts drawn that
way because they don't want it drawn
that way because they want to turn Texas
blue so what is their lawsuit based on
based on the fact that we don't like
Texas and what did Bill Barr do them
nothing yeah nothing Republic you know
look Republicans and Democrats they're
both establishment the reason the
Republicans haven't been doing anything
for years is because they're just
stopping the populist movement and and
the working class from actually getting
anything done and the Democrats because
they have a bunch of
ignorant young people just marching
blindly behind them they're able to you
know crack the whip and get away with it
because of the tribal nature of what
they're what they're what they're doing
but I mean this should be alarm bells to
anybody Trump starts a media company and
also in the SEC is investigating huh
dude I'm calling BS on that come on we
saw what happened with Obama and the Tea
Party and the IRS using the power of the
government to harass and coerce and go
after anyone who opposes you
Yep this is just them vying for power
and when they have power they of course
conceal it for themselves use it for
their own personal benefit uh and when
you see it from that perspective these
larger kind of spats and fights kind of
do make sense because it's you know the
left wing versus the right wing
um so we we have seen that this abused
so much and I remember even doing a news
story about 10 years ago talking about
how social media could decide elections
there was numerous studies being done
that came to the conclusion saying if
you just tweak the algorithm a little
bit if you just tweak what people see
and don't see you could literally change
the future of this country this was
something that we were talking about 10
years ago I think this has become
something that's not just a possibility
I think it's a reality and I think we
need to acknowledge what you mentioned
is that big Tech social media does
affect elections does affect who gets
voted in and of course they have a clear
side with anyone who of course does
their bidding who of course anyone who
works for them and is willing to help
them out at the end of the day and they
have cure a pure Financial interest
right I mean look at some of the players
in this um not social media but it's
media Michael Bloomberg one of the top
10 richest people in the nation uh the
two guys from Google alphabet uh top
five richest people in uh the nation
Zuckerberg top five richest people in
the uh who goes to Bilderberg and
burning man yeah
um and then he's the man who helped
start one of the major super Pacs that
that of course spread the first kind of
term of of Russian collusion yeah so so
there's they're integrated in so many
different ways Eric Schmidt said he that
he uh supports Hillary Clinton he backed
her in so many different ways but he
there's so many other things happening
behind the scenes that aren't even
public that we don't even know about
that truly do highlight the bigger power
plays at hand here behind the scenes and
obviously right now the power
establishment that's in charge is the
corporate neoliberal uh fascistic
establishment that is parading itself as
a social justice Warrior woke ideology
when in reality there they are
technocrats and that's exactly what I
would call them absolutely and total
authoritarians because they also support
black lives matter if you ask them they
they were all behind the Russia
collusion they probably all support
vaccine mandates and they're all worth
60. they only support black lives matter
when it supports their divide and
conquer agenda when at the same time
they pass initiatives that largely
discriminate against them just like
these larger vax mandates predominantly
discriminate against black people and
now not only their opportunity to go to
places inside but now their opportunity
to even find a job where in New York
City predominantly the majority of
people who haven't taken the vaccine are
black now they can't get a job no so
okay go to the library you can't go to
the library
they took away all their economic
opportunities but these are the same
people cheerleading we support black
lives matter no matter what no you don't
you support your agenda and they use the
power of the government to crush their
opposition exactly but we got something
interesting here Devin Nunes is retiring
oh yeah so he's going to be joining the
Trump media firm and I can't say I'm
surprised that the feds are going after
Trump's media firm but he wrote a letter
he basically said um Nuna said in a
letter to his constituents that he'll be
leaving at the end of 2021 prior to the
2022 midterms recently I was presented
with an opportunity to fight for the
most important issues I believe in I'm
writing to let you know I've decided to
pursue this opportunity and therefore I
will be leaving the House of
Representatives at the end of 2021. rest
assured I have not by any means given up
our Collective fight I'll just be
pursuing it through other means
so uh Nunes announced his resignation
the Trump and media Technology Group
released a statement saying Nunes would
be the company's chief executive officer
I would love to see uh to have Devin on
the show to discuss this Mr Nunes
congressman and talk about what's going
on with this because I certainly
believed Evan Nunez is a fighter so I've
been concerned about what's been
happening with like the acquisition of
of locals and stuff
seeing this I do think there's another
risk of big Tech just because they say
they're going to protect us and protect
our rights and allow Free Speech doesn't
mean that in five years time they
actually will it'll be other people with
other interests another agenda in power
and the ability to censor you so I'm all
about decentralizing this stuff and then
hooking into the machine what these
people have been doing have been
building a centralized system just to
give themselves power so it's it's one
thing to be like I believe everyone
should have access to communication and
that's another thing to see two warring
factions arguing over who which which
one of them gets to have control over
the means of communication right yeah I
think the interesting thing about Nunez
retiring I just wanted to confirm that
he is from California he is from
California
um which means the governor will
renounce his replacement
um Pelosi does not have a very big
majority he would not risk the larger
right-of-center agenda if he thought
anything was in Risk so I think Devin
Nunes knows nothing's going to happen
next year like my being there or
replacing me with the Democrat is going
to mean absolutely nothing to the agenda
what does that mean does that mean the
Republicans are aren't going to win that
no that means that the the house will be
in total stalled next year they're not
going to get anything through the Senate
that they'll just be on vacation that's
my hunch I don't think he would leave oh
right right if he was like yeah we have
these really big bills that are coming
up I got to be there because we only
have a three vote lead right right right
right he's like he's right it doesn't
make a difference he's right I mean it's
Tribal right now the Democrats have the
house and it's not going to be until
what January 3rd 2023 before even if the
Redway Red Wave happens and think of how
sad that is in terms of just Civics that
we are already dismissing all of next
year nothing will happen in DC billions
I like that it is that sounds great to
me what a colossal waste of space and
time and money all these people are
going to be flying here and they're
going to be having meetings people like
you you describe the perfect definition
of government right there that was it
say that sentence
in and they're gonna have these hearings
but no it's just how how how
embarrassing is it like it's all just a
joke it's just a hit it always was I
know it always has been that it always
was and I and I take a a stagnant
government that keeps fighting itself
and doesn't accomplish anything and
doesn't pass new rules and laws is the
best government and in the active
government is the best government people
could ask for because it doesn't get
involved in anyone's business I I I
disagree Luke at this point um a
government that begins repealing laws
and adding Sunset Clauses to uh you know
existing laws is the kind of government
we need if the Republicans had a
backbone and actually did some of that I
would agree with you but they don't they
usually comply and they just want to add
new bureaucracies new jurisdictions and
new regulations that gives them power
and gives them Authority yeah I wish
there was a political system or a
political party that represented
repealing a lot of the bureaucracy
repealing a lot of the dumb regulations
that hurt small businesses that prevent
people from competing with Amazon and
Walmart and Costco and whoever it may be
that's the Department of Commerce yeah
17 000 people work there look at what a
good job they're doing yeah right yeah
so I I wish there was the the slow kind
of recalling of all this nonsense I wish
we just had one rule we talked about
this on the show a number of times just
make make a sunset clause on all laws on
all rules on all regulations just let
them expire uh please because there's so
much bullcrap that the average American
has to deal with every single day when
it comes to a mafioso middleman uh
government Thug interfering in their
livelihoods it's it's impossible to make
ends meet for a lot I wish the founding
fathers added an additional amendment
that you know the Constitution can be
amended in these ways however statutory
laws passed by Congress will all have a
natural Sunset period And the reason for
that is and they could have they could
have done like a natural Sunset of 20
years or something to recognize rules
change by generation and new generations
coming in will need to assess the rules
of the previous generation determine if
they're still you know applicable to
what's what our society is like today
and I think then you have the
Constitution which is mostly immutable
it's very difficult to change but can be
amended if everyone comes together and
and mostly agrees and then when it comes
to statutory law these things got to get
reviewed because right now if they put
up I would say this in about 10 years I
I'm willing to bet gun control is going
to be in the gutter
2A Advocates are winning they're winning
like crazy and that means the younger
generation the leftists who are pro-gun
and the right populists and The
Independents and Libertarians are
winning on this front absolutely
they would be like oh we're going to
review this NFA thing throw it in the
gutter that being said they can go in
and then be like hey we're all going to
vote to throw this NFA thing in the
gutter so that's
in my opinion a good thing but I think
with sunset Clauses it makes it happen a
little bit faster where whereas you
might need a certain amount of votes to
get past a filibuster or get it through
a veto with a sunset if they don't vote
to uphold it it just gone whereas right
now if they say you know we're going to
pass the the repealing the NFA act and
then Biden's just like veto to get out
of here and then they're like we can't
get the two-thirds majority to you know
to get the to overrun override The veto
so you can't do it with the sunset they
just be like
ain't nobody voting for it so we got a
simple majority it's out that'd be
fantastic but speaking of guns let's
talk about some uh some cultural stuff
uh I want to talk about Alec Baldwin we
got some interesting news in the Alec
Baldwin front from deadline Alec Baldwin
today deleted his Twitter account and so
did Hilaria Baldwin Days After Shock ABC
interview and I will tell you my
thoughts I think he deleted his account
because his lawyers were like you dumb
mother effort
everything you said incriminated you in
killing this woman and I am uh uh I
wouldn't say I'm more convinced than
ever that he's a that he's intentionally
committed murder I would say that
interview that Alec Baldwin did with
George Stephanopoulos was incredibly
incriminating and it sounds to me like
the probability that he did
intentionally murder this woman went up
a decent amount and I would put it at
like I don't know if I were to think
like what percentage of me thinks he
intentionally killed this woman it's
like 26 27 and then like 20 says it was
an accident whenever but this whole
interview
it says to me this guy he did it
something's wrong there it's beyond
wrong man yeah I mean have you been
following the story I have I have no
absolutely and I I was surprised that he
actually gave an interview because if
you're under any investigation the last
thing you want to do is have more words
that Canon will be used against you
that's why you're you have the right to
remain silent
um so I don't understand why he did this
interview I also found it funny that he
chose Stephanopoulos because uh Steffy
probably thinks he is getting these
these big hits and like he's he's got to
have some some cool feature but really
it's because they know he's just an easy
interview if you are in trouble and
you're on the left go to Steffi
Stephanopoulos and and you will get a
cakewalk but even with the Cakewalk I
mean imagine if he went to a real
journalist imagine if he sat down with
someone who actually asked him oh I
watched roasted this guy oh so he went
to George Stephanopoulos for a cakewalk
and even in that Kate walk he said a lot
of stuff like the fact that he did or
did not pull us pull the trigger even
well a lot of people are saying that
this is rude to the fam family that's
still in mourning that he's making this
kind of big media spectacle around this
and it's also I you know if looking from
the outside it's also kind of psychotic
to try to Proclaim yourself as a victim
here which which he was in in my kind of
uh you know understanding of it was
trying to make himself out to be making
him the center of attention around this
when in reality you know this was a very
emotional issue that I don't think helps
anyone in this situation yeah well let's
let's talk about some of the facts and
some of the things he said and I'll I'll
just get straight to it one of the
things that really caught me was when he
made this argument Stephanopoulos asks
Alec Baldwin but I'll give you the quick
the quick elevator pictures to whatever
Alec bald was on the set of the movie
rust he pulled out a gun pulled it
pulled the hammer back fired it killed a
cinematographer and struck the director
the there's a lot of other Nuance
details we'll get into a second but
Stephanopoulos said why didn't you check
the gun
and Baldwin said you can't
when you're handed a weapon if I were to
open the the chamber or take the clip
out I know he said clip he meant
magazine he's like they would
immediately take it away from me because
it's been checked by someone else you
know he probably thought that was a
really good argument he probably was
thinking about doing the interview
talking to some people and they were
like oh tell them you can't check the
gun because then they would take it away
from you the idea being if they saw if
the armorer was checking the weapon
taking it apart putting it back together
checking the rounds hands it to Alec
Baldwin and then he opens it up and does
something to it the armor is now like yo
I just checked this what did you do give
that back to me I'm checking it again
but that's a really dumb thing to say
because I'll tell you this ah so Alec
Baldwin you recognize that the armor or
prop guy as he calls it hands you a
weapon you can't do anything because
that guy has to make sure it's checked
correct yes then why was it that when
you were handed the weapon by the A.D
who is not the prop person or the
armorer you did not find that suspect
enough to call for the prop guy and say
please check the weapon someone had
manipulated it if your argument is you
can't check it because they would take
it from you to check why didn't you call
for that when it was handled by someone
who wasn't the armorer that in my
opinion is incriminating additionally he
claimed when he was on the street and
the people the paparazzi were filming
him he was like she was my friend she
was my friend in this interview he was
asked what did you know about Helena
Hutchins nothing nothing until she came
on set she was your friend but you
didn't know her until she took this job
he didn't know she was so why was he
having dinner with her why was Alec
Baldwin having dinner with someone who
wasn't his friend he had just met that
could be that they're working on set and
they said let's go grab dinner and talk
about the movie but at the same time we
know that there was Labor concerns the
crew was complaining about safety
conditions and and pay and people were
walking off then we find out Baldwin's
having a a dinner with him he doesn't
know and he describes her in the
interview as intense not interested in
small talk just getting down to business
so I don't know
you would have to believe that Alec
Baldwin was handed this gun popped open
the the so these are single action
revolvers there's a little latch on the
right side you pop it open and then you
can see and you put the bullet in spin
the cylinder doesn't come out like you
see in like the video game so they flip
it out the single action so we'd have to
open the latch one by one load it while
spinning this you know spinning this uh
the cylinder and if he wanted to put a
bullet in it he'd have to put one in and
then close it very easy to do with in my
opinion I think it's a bit of a stretch
to assume that Alec Baldwin with one
hand was holding around reached over
because he had the gun on his side and
then popped it open pushed the ball in
and pulled it out and then shot her but
I also think it's even it's it's it's
still more absurd to assume that the gun
had to be accidentally loaded with live
rounds to be to get given to a guy who's
not supposed to handle it to be handed
to Alec Baldwin who's not supposed to
use it in this set to then Alec Baldwin
claimed that Helena Hutchins told him to
point the gun at her and pull the hammer
back I'm like
I'm sorry if I'm if if that's the
official story and the alternative is
Alec Baldwin put a bullet a gun and shot
a woman I think that Alec Baldwin put a
bullet and shot a woman is much more
likely to be true but I'm not saying
it's definitive I don't know I'm just
saying it's more likely is he saying
that she said uh point the gun at me and
shoot at me because she's
cinematographer she's got a camera she
wants a POV director camera shot is what
she's she's looking to to shoot yes okay
he was saying she kept saying you know
draw the gun Tarantino S Type angle
where you're literally looking right at
the camera or or at a slight angle and
so the camera's here and she's just to
the right of it and the gun is going
slightly off yeah but I'm sorry if his
argument is she was telling me over and
over again to draw the gun and point it
at me and then he says she told me to
pull the hammer back and then I let go
and I it just fired I didn't pull the
trigger that's not possible on a single
action revolver unless he was holding
the trigger depressed while pulling it
back which also seems like a strange
thing to do so all of these weird I said
at this last month I was like all of
these coincidences had to have occurred
for Alec Baldwin to have accidentally
shot this woman sorry dude he was
holding a single action revolver you
pull the hammer back and goes click
click I think I may even go click click
click you can't just let it go it
doesn't go forward until you pull that
trigger so someone accidentally puts a
bullet in it and gives it to the wrong
guy Alec Baldwin knows that's not
supposed to be the guy who has it and
he's supposed to get the armor to come
check it because it was manipulated by
somebody else and then Helena Hutchins
is like yes draw the weapon and aim it
at me now pull the hammer back oh no
I've been shot directly through the
chest hitting my spine and killing her
I'm sorry dude Baldwin straight up
killed that lady going through her and
hitting another person uh behind her as
well actor John Schneider he was in The
Dukes of Hazzard came out and said that
he doubts that this gun went off by
itself he also called the whole
interview bull-ish uh family-friendly
show you know what I'm trying to say but
he said that it was designed to quote
make us feel sorry for Alec Baldwin and
I think he made some very interesting
points surrounding this it doesn't
matter you see the guy do the Youtube
video
um I'm not sure which guy the guy from
uh what show John Schneider yeah he was
vote Duke yes yes yes yes yes and he he
I I think it's the guy who took the the
single action he he took it apart and he
showed you exactly how was this and he
said that there was a propaganda uh
propaganda machine behind all of this
and as we know uh Alec Baldwin has has
been working with PR emergency companies
that have been implementing uh a lot of
the kind of fake news have been
implementing a lot of uh the the kind of
noise around this matter allegedly
according to a lot of sources surrounded
in this case so it wouldn't be so
surprising to me if a crisis manager
came to Alice Baldwin and said okay
we're going to sit you down we're going
to get rid of all this public pressure
we're going to make sure you get back
into acting very soon and Alex said
whatever it takes
um and and I think this was a part of
the process that he taught would help
him but in in reality a lot of other
people are calling him out you know
what's really weird is that this woman
was an investigative journalist yeah
and a lot of people are there's there's
investigating the clintons well I know I
know but there are a lot of people
pushing something like that yeah and I
don't see evidence for that and I do
think that's an attempt to push people
away from the real story you got to be
careful with these really crazy
conspiracies about you know kids in
basements at pizza parlors because it is
it is so absurd and easily disproven but
people believe the trash they read on
the internet what happens is you have
this very serious story about Alec
Baldwin who killed Owen we don't know
why she did work as we have it here on a
Wikipedia page she has a degree in
international journalism and worked on
documentary films as an investigative
journalist in Eastern Europe
so all of a sudden you know she now
finds herself working as a
cinematographer from the past for the
past few years
this woman was killed let's get to the
bottom of it but if people start pushing
these crazy theories about the the
secret undercover investigation she was
really pursuing then all of a sudden you
lose interest CNN comes out and says
it's a crackpot conspiracy it was on all
an accident and like that actor guy said
there's a propaganda machine trying to
make us feel sorry for Alec Baldwin when
he killed this woman yeah and I think I
think you raised a great point that if
you're Alec Baldwin's agent and his PR
staff the question is how do we get you
back to acting as fast as possible and
you look at the history of some
Hollywood unsavory actors I mean heck
Roman polanski's gets standing ovations
at the Oscars yeah I mean because her
his PR machine was so good now granted
he's extradited in France so right he
can't come back and he won't come back
because he knows he'll get arrested but
Hollywood actors and actresses will
still applaud Roman polanskin yes he
raped a 15 year old girl but he's a
brilliant director and I'm sure if
you're Alec Baldwin's people you're like
what's that compared to Roman Polanski
or Harvey Weinstein or so many other
people in Hollywood
yeah wasn't there a famous actress that
made a speech about him saying we need
him back we should get him back it's
unfair what was her name was it I can't
remember was it Barbara or was it uh
Whoopi was it was that Meryl Streeper
was someone someone did a major major
actress did give a like we need him yes
we need him back was it the gap tooth
one
um what's her name uh this was from the
family
um the the whole all the families uh uh
what the heck's her name I just think
Alec Baldwin if you know look
I don't see how an accident it's it's
it's it's it's it's it's it's it's like
um final destination you know that movie
where the series of movies where the
people die in really weird ways like a
truck is driving on the street and then
some guy spills his coffee which like so
he throws it out the window and then it
bounces and then it hits a sign which
causes the sign to spin around and then
point in the wrong direction and then a
truck turns left but then slips on ice
and flips over and then the logs fly off
the truck bounce through the air hit a
car which makes the car fly off a bridge
and then hit a guy like that's what it
sounds like to me when when they explain
that this the scenario that happened
according to Alec Baldwin or there's the
really simple like more real-life angry
crew members Alec Baldwin was frustrated
tired angry has a temper and he said
screw this bang was he not supposed to
have a gun in that scene I heard that
the officials the official story uh from
the script supervisor and the
electrician was that he he was supposed
to have a gun but he wasn't supposed to
draw it or aim it and it wasn't supposed
to be handed to him by this this uh
assistant director so if he wasn't
supposed to draw or aim it why would
Helena Hutchins tell him to draw it and
point it at her well she's dead and she
can't tell us exactly why that was
happening the weird thing is and I'm
sure everyone's afraid to go public
because this is an ongoing investigation
with the exception of I've worked on a
lot of Hollywood scenes it was one of my
earlier little things long long time ago
there are no scenes that there are just
three or four people porn shoots have
staffs of 15 people right A lot of
people saw this happen the fact that
none of them have come out publicly and
said what happened they're probably all
afraid they probably all have this is
this is definitely recorded on film
there's a lot of people who witness this
they're waiting for the investigation to
go I'll tell you that's right and I will
say one last thing if you don't mind
I've worked on movies with with uh
oscar-winning actors and oscar-winning
cinematographers oscar-winning actors
don't have dinner with cinematographers
like the stat didn't work with the staff
unless something is wrong an a-lister
meeting with a a new cinematographer he
just said it must have to do with the
crew something is wrong or like they
were like Alec you gotta take her out to
dinner because like she's gotta win her
over or she's only one putting up with
your BS so you and he was like fine I'll
do it but I've been on movie sets where
this they don't that they don't yeah the
staff are pissed off because of the
budgeting they said that he was
undercutting everyone and not properly
funding the production of this movie and
they were saying this is this is
absolutely absurd so that could have
been you know the arguments that
happened there uh and again we don't
know we're not you know we can only
speculate from here you know the whole
where Alec was saying if I had taken the
gun apart to check they would have taken
it away from me thing is such a pansy
like that's what he would have done to
someone as the producer if he saw
someone checking inspecting their weapon
he would have taken out of their hands
and fired the guy because he's he's lost
because he doesn't have he's impatient
he doesn't have patience I see what
you're saying but he's just lying that's
also positive like George Clooney was
like I always check yeah because you get
in trouble if Alec Baldwin is like I I
didn't check because they told me I
wasn't supposed to it's like well you
realize that's still involuntary
manslaughter right like so that's a BS
argument and it sounded clever he
probably thought in his mind this one
makes a lot of sense and then all it
does is incriminate him oh so you're
saying you knew the guy who was
manipulating it wasn't supposed to hand
it to you and you fired it anyway you
knew that if someone manipulates the gun
other than the prop guy it must be
handed back to the prop guy and you
still took it aimed it at her pulled the
hammer back and fired it and but in his
mind the story was so good just like our
friend Jesse Smollett in his mind his
story was so good and he also did media
again all these people with these
terrible stories who are like I should
go do a live interview and incriminate
myself prince Andrew don't give any
interviews Jessie Smollett no no give
interviews including prince Andrew more
interviews we need everyone Jesse
Smollett testifies today I couldn't
believe it they're saying this guy may
be convicted as soon as two models oh my
gosh Jesse Smollett by the time you guys
so we're live right now when we record
this but tomorrow morning this one's
going to go up and it may be but by the
time you find this video Smollett has
already been found guilty by a jury of
his peers because it has been a disaster
in this case yeah they were experts were
saying the only defense he has is for
him to testify and it's let's you got to
hear this if you've not been following
this you are grab the popcorn you are
gonna laugh so first this guy claims
the defense that the ocean dyro brothers
that he hired according to the
prosecutors to Stage this hoax are
sophisticated criminals who framed him
they claimed the whole thing even though
he paid them for workout training and
then told the cops they were white they
planned the whole thing to frame him why
because they're homophobic and they hate
him oh then you get the uh what happens
is during during testimony the defense
tries cross-examining one of the ocean
Darrow brothers and the judge said that
it was like collateral or something in a
move on and so you I got you just get
ready for the suspense the the the the
defense attorney calls for a sidebar to
speak with the judge demands a mistrial
because they were saying that they're
not being properly allowed to uh
cross-examine then claims the judge
lunged at her Demands a mistrial over
that the judge says that's BS that never
happened and you're not getting a
mistrial and then the defense started
crying and left the courtroom with her
mother I am not making that up the
attorney yes left with her mother
is this not on camera how this is a this
is a violation of our human rights
[Laughter]
the whole cast of Empires watching this
like this show is fantastic I would have
to say that Jesse Smollett is trying to
use the Kevin Spacey defense if you
remember Kevin Spacey was accused of
doing some absolutely horrendous
horrible things to underaged children
particularly boys and his main defense
was hey I'm gay and because of that the
mainstream corporate press literally ran
with headlines Brave actor Kevin Spacey
comes out as gay and that somehow
obfuscated that the larger accusations
very serious accusations of him doing
horrible things to small children and
now Jesse smollett's main argument here
is that he's gay and he does gay stuff
that's his main defense exclusively here
and when that's your defense I don't
think you have a winning case here no
it's a lifestyle not a defense and all
right it's crazy I so I pulled this up
we got Breitbart and we got the New York
Post on Thursday so let's attorney
tomorrow Walker requested a mistrial
over her claims Cook County Judge James
Lynn uh physically lunged at her CBS
news reports Reports say the encounter
happened during a sidebar conversation
with attorneys from both sides the judge
denied the accusations and also denied
the motion for mistrial Walker
reportedly appeared to be close to tears
while debating with the judge and left
the courtroom with her mother while the
rest of smilet's Team continued to ask
for a measure okay close to tears sorry
I said she cried she was close to tears
as she left with her mother that is
Jesse smollett's defense team if you're
a defense lawyer cries out for mommy in
the courtroom that's a bad sign that's
bad you know what happened was she went
up and was like saying something to the
judge and getting his face and he went
you're like he leaned at her and went
you I am the law here and got real
serious and then she considered that
like an attack but he's like
establishing order I'm PR that's that's
probably exactly what happened you know
yeah
she brought her mom with her is she like
fresh out of law school like it's her
first trial and Jesse's like I'm gonna
I'm gonna give her a chance you know on
my life to like leave the defense in the
New York Post reports the same thing she
was near tears and she left the get she
left the court with her mother who was
in The Gallery as the rest of samat's
Team continue to ask for a mistrial did
Jesse did juicy smallett hire Elwood
from Legally Legally Blonde no no we're
from Legally Blonde I'm like maybe he's
hoping she'll have her breakthrough
moment in the courtroom you know and
she'll realize that that he's innocent I
mean and this is one comment that I'm
seeing uh right now and it's uh that
Jesse Smollett the first American to
scam Nigerians
and I think they have a point good Lord
but he actually testified and uh let's
read this from CNN they say former
Empire star uh Jesse Smollett took the
stand in the star like I'm sorry they
said actor I said I I made it up said
former Empire actor Jessica took the
stand in the ongoing criminal trial
Monday and a high stakes attempt to
rebut charges that he staged a fake hate
crime they say under oath Monday solet
offered testimony over more than two
hours that suggested the brothers whom
he knew from the Empire set may have had
other motivations he said Bola osendaira
who he called ban helped get him drugs
including cocaine he also said they had
a sexual relationship uh between them at
a particular Chicago bath house one
night while the two were out and
Smollett testified they got a private
room and did drugs and like made out on
a separate occasion smallett told jurors
he and Bola snuck away from from his
brother after the three right of female
strip club together so molette testified
again they got a private room and made
out a little bit and uh family-friendly
show you know had fun together let's
just I don't have relations I don't know
how this is you don't need to go there
imagine you're the jury Jeffrey two been
together
you're the jury if you're the jury and
he's just saying all this stuff you're
like yo I don't know what this has to do
with anything so they say he kind of
creeped me out every time we were around
him he didn't speak to me every time we
needed to leave he made it seem like we
needed a sneak off after a hate letter
was sent to him smilet said Bola
osandera approached him about becoming
his personal security guard something
the actor told the jury osendaro had
repeatedly asked him following the
letter bolosandara began asking him more
about the need for security that's all
that said the actor described being
annoyed at the idea of always having a
security detail around them
around lunchtime I would smoke my blunt
drive around the neighborhood of the
studios I don't want to be in someone's
car solet told the jury that while
driving around with Bola there was never
any discussion of planning a staged hate
attack did you talk to him about some
hoax no Smollett said so it sounds like
Jesse Smith's argument is this guy
staged the attack because he was trying
to convince him to hire him as a
security guard and that I mean that's a
story I don't see any evidence to claim
that's true because Smollett paid him
for personal training and the idea that
these guys were white when that's what
Smollett said which is like he lied you
know yeah so so if they did this to
convince you that you needed security
you call the cops but you didn't
immediately point to them that these are
the guys who did it you didn't and you
were still wearing the Noose and you
still had your soda and your Subway
sandwich they did a dry run of this they
have they have the Nigerian Brothers go
into a store and literally pick up a
black masks right the rope that they
used and and
they he wrote a checkup to them yeah
well on tomorrow's show if he is found
guilty and you have this breaking news
for the show
um I I tweeted a couple of days ago that
I think his punishment should be very
simple he should have to go to the next
Mega rally and he should have to look at
the president Trump and he should have
to apologize oh don't put him in jail
it's a waste of taxpayer dollars from to
go to jail he should have to repay all
of the legal work and the police workers
says that they're going to potentially
charge him hundreds of thousands of
dollars for that larger investigation
it's a waste of he's going to get killed
in jail probably um I don't think he's
going to get he shouldn't go to jail but
for those of us people who are in Camp
Maga who they made a huge deal of this
in 19 and he did the whole press circuit
and they were like this is indicative of
the types of people who vote for Donald
Trump for all of us who who proudly
voted for Donald Trump who were sick and
tired of being besmirched by people like
juicy Smollett he owes us an apology and
we should get a sincere one and a
sincere one for me is being in front of
tens of thousands of us don't write us a
little letter or do a YouTube video you
have to stand there and face us and
listen to us either Heckle you or
knowing Trump people they'll probably
give him a little Applause and say get
him off the stage I I just feel like I'm
kind of done trying to convince people
who are in The Cult yeah people who
believed this story the people who
believed the Covington lies the people
believe Russia gate Ukraine gate all
that garbage who fell for the lie after
life after lie and each and every one of
those stories has been definitively
debunked the media lied yeah what's the
point of trying to convince people who
want to be lied to and lied to I mean
Justice Mallette apparently has
supporters outside the courtroom like
cheering for him
whatever and look serial killers get it
too man serial killers have get letters
from ladies who are like I love you you
know so whatever man
um what's the point I think a regular
person hears the story and they
immediately just are like yeah okay
that's BS and I'm like there we go what
more do we need to be saying about this
I'm glad though
because I do think justice justice
Millet is contributing to the people
waking up to what's going on yeah
because well you had Big Bang Theory
with the you know they did the group
photo and everyone coming out and being
like I can't believe this happened and
blaming Trump supporters and it was just
very obviously not true yeah yeah and
it's a frustrating thing because it also
does an awful lot of damage to uh people
who are attacked real I don't I don't
believe in hate crimes I don't believe
in hate speech
um but we use that term uh but but it
does do a lot of damage to people who
are victims of crime you know and also
how many police resources were diverted
right it's the same thing of like the
Bubba Watson incident how many FBI
agents does it take to go investigate a
NASCAR right when if these resources are
so limited and so expensive how many
people Chicago this year just hit its
eight and it's your home City I like to
talk about New York as well Chicago just
hit it it's eighth hundredth homicide
this year how many detectives could have
been diverted to the streets to whatever
but we're doing the Jesse Smollett
investigation right so I mean those are
the people who deserve the true apology
you stole resources from a very very
tortured City it's true it's true but I
also got to say like Chicago's got very
serious problems with police corruption
and they've always had it's been a mob
town as long as I've known it and if you
look at history it's always been a mob
town and I'm kind of like torn between
yeah maybe there could become some cops
stopping you know some of these gun
crimes and homicides and stuff but then
I remember when Chicago operated black
sites where they arrested people without
charge and held them there for 10 days
that notifying anybody or when that one
guy was electrocuting people to force
confessions so at that point I'm kind of
like I don't know whatever I'm not going
to give them anything we got Tracked
Down by the Chicago PD and had a you
know I had a gun point to that me
because of just journalism you know yeah
we got surrounded by a bunch of cars
they took the cop cars on marks unmarked
took us out searched us it was all
completely unwarranted they apparently
rated the apartment we were staying at
the whole crazy story went down they
tried planting drugs on us just real
real dirty stuff Chicago is a dirty City
they there's I can't remember the guy's
name do you guys remember the the name
of the guy in Chicago who was cattle
prodding people into forcing them to
confessions yeah I'm not a fan of the
CPD man whatever happened to that that
black site that the Chicago Police
Department was running do you know much
about it it was uh common square is that
what it was called yeah Homan Square
home and square looked it up yeah yeah
no it was unmarked location where they
would bring people to like you know
effectively torture you know City at War
man is that still operate I don't know I
haven't been in Chicago I I moved out of
Chicago uh 13 years ago
yeah 13 years ago and uh got rid of that
story broke in 2015. yeah that's nuts
it's crazy right so look man I like the
idea of you know the good local cop
who's like look I just want to make sure
people aren't getting hurt and I've met
some of these guys but you look at some
of these big cities like New York
Chicago and la and they are crooked
super crooked New York is super crooked
Chicago super crooked the small towns
you tend to tend to be okay but you
still get a lot of cops who are willing
to just do what they're told yeah I kind
of agree with you Daniel about I don't
think putting him in jail solves
anything at this point but but like a a
public apology might actually do more
good for society yeah for Jesse I don't
know yeah at least for me I want my
apology I gotta I gotta I gotta read
this uh from uh the Super Chat we're
gonna we're gonna go to super chats but
real quick first I guess read this one
that just came in Kennedy says you know
how I know Tim isn't really from Chicago
because it says people should get hot
dogs at Portillo's that's like saying go
get pizza at Gino's no we went to
Portillo lows on Harlem and Archer we
love Portillos there was always a
massive line people in Chicago love
their Portillos they got ribs they got
Italian beef you get the beef dipped you
get it with sweet peppers or you get the
giardiniera if you want it but okay to
be fair we would also go to Maxwell
Street because we had one and it's just
off of Cicero at like 65th so we'd go
there pretty often often and that's
awesome too but hey man I I actually
agree and I was saying this earlier
because we did order from Portillo's I
was like to be fair ordering for
Portillos is like telling people to go
get a hot dog and tell them to go to
Giordano's like if you want to get real
Chicago Pizza you got to find a good
local spot you want to get a good hot
dog you got to find a good hole in the
wall but I took I took a fence at that I
like Portillos all right if you're in
Chicago you can check that out and get
the gravy you ever have gravy bread yeah
that is they literally take like a
French roll and they dunk it in gravy to
soggy bread and they put in the thing
and that's it that's what you eat that's
it that's it that's it it's like 50
cents or a dollar whatever very probably
not healthy at all delicious that's
probably fantastic my ears worked up but
we've had it here because you can order
them uh the Italian beef is so good you
get the beef you put it in I like sweet
peppers you put supers on top and then
you take the whole sandwich and just
dunk it in the whole beef thing with
gravy and eat it and the bread's all
soggy that's what you're supposed to do
that's right you know you know what I
missed too you can't get anywhere is
jardiniera pizza
so uh jardinera mix it's like what is it
cauliflower jalapenos carrots vinegar
and vinegar have you ever had a note
yeah it's very common on Italian food
I've never had it on pizza that's kind
of an Abomination no man it's so good
it's so good you go to Chicago you order
a local Chicago place they just put
jardinero over it and it is my favorite
but you know what when I went to New
York for the first time and I was
ordering a hero that's what they call it
called a hero yeah that's crazy no a
hero
h-e-r-o it's a sandwich
a hero and so I was like I'm looking at
the board I'm like what's a hero and the
guy's like sandwich and he points to the
roll and I was like oh like a like a
like a hoagie
or something and then I was like I'll
get one of those and I'll get you know
I'll get I'll get the roast beef with
cheddar and some jardinera and the guy
goes and with what and I was like uh do
you have jardinera and he goes what and
I was like jardinera and he goes I don't
know what you're talking about and I was
like whoa dude when you make the Jordan
Air Pizza do you bake the jardinera you
just put it on top of the pizza and then
you bake it yeah oh yeah okay yeah that
baked cauliflower I bet would be really
good and whole cloves of garlic oh yeah
people think Chicago pizza is deep dish
that's not true that's tourist pizza
real Chicago pizza has like a sturdy
thin crust with like a thick layer of
cheese on it the deep dish is not pizza
it's tomato casserole it's very lovely
but it's not pizza I agree it's like
doing a pizza but we're going to start a
New York Chicago rivalry here and New
York historically I win New York Pizza
is really thin it's floppy right you
fold it you know three fingers and it's
kind of flowers but if it flops in the
end no good it should hold up straight
it should hold it a real Chicago pizza
is actually a it's a firm crust it
doesn't rise up like in New York where
you get that crust it's thin all the way
around and they cut into squares that's
like most squares squares most Chicago
local pizza places do pizza like that or
at least they used to now we're starting
to see New York style take over slices
and then yeah slices and the big crust
in the back anyway let's read super
chats out debating pizza and stuff in
Chicago I'm kind of hungry now actually
I'm not gonna lie we actually did a big
order of Portillo's and we had hot dog
you know everyone had hot dogs we had
hot dogs earlier today too you boil them
so yeah Luke had the Chicago style it's
got Tomatoes got a pickle it's got sport
Peppers it's got celery salt it's got
relish onion mustard smells like a
sandwich that's a lot of stuff on one
huh that's the Chicago hot dog man even
without the bread still all right we
gotta Read Super chats laughs all right
so we got a lot of people pointing out
Patriot front Padre mortala says y'all
should take a uh you should talk and
make fun of the glowy group Patriot
front at least for a little bit the
March on Washington was hilariously
glowy that means like it was a bunch of
Feds that was funny I mean it just seems
so ridiculously fake but is is the
implication that like a large group of
hundreds of federal agents all got
together and wore uniforms they were all
between five foot ten and a half and six
foot two that they all had 34 waist like
I've never seen a more fit uh you like
like tall like it was beautiful hey if
that's the future that they want in
America I support it because they all
looked great they're all healthy and but
they're crazy they're creepy weirdos and
it's funny when you look at these when
you're fake when you look at the actual
right-wing rallies it's a bunch of fat
dudes yeah exactly like the funniest
thing to see photos of guys and like
trying to hide under our vest that were
a little point tactical gear with guns
and they're morbidly obese and I'm like
look no offense dude but you like you're
not going to be able to run to actually
deal with any kind of conflict you you
you're not you're not fit for this like
the the things that the military goes
through to be ready when they do pt and
stuff but hey man you know whatever
I also wanted to bring it up and the
knee pads was very bizarre I don't know
what I well there's a family-friendly
show but there was a lot of knee pads a
lot of knee pads they were all wearing
them oh my gosh were you all catchers at
the at the last softball game like what
what is that they call it now yeah like
softball all right Willie Bryce says Tim
McGraw my employer announced today that
those vaccinated will get an extra 80 a
week I can't help but feel disrespected
and discriminated against you see that's
not see they're not going to punish you
they're going to promote everybody else
yeah that's how they'll do it motivate
you and then if you want to get that
sweet 80 bucks you got to do as you're
told but do it see that's the game if
you're a business you can just be like
oh okay we're not punishing you we're
just giving everybody who gets it a
bonus yeah you know a raise is it I
think it's coercive I don't know I don't
know there's challenges to what private
businesses are allowed to do and who
they want to work with but I think scale
is a big issue if Walmart tries to do it
I'm like nah you're too big you know but
if you're a small business old dude and
you've got like three employees I'm like
maybe then we just say let the old man
do his thing you know what I mean it's
tough it's tough
all right let's see
the Scott 16 says
follow the science they say okay the
companies that make these vaccines
recommend against kids getting them is
that is that true are they doing that I
I don't know if that's the case is it
what do you how do you mean like Pfizer
I said kids shouldn't get it I did not
hear that yeah yeah I'm pretty sure
they're pushing it yeah I'm pretty sure
the Pfizer like the CEOs of all these
companies are like everybody should get
it and modernist CEO is like you should
get two more yeah yeah they're selling
you a product I don't think they're
trying to stop people from taking it
subscription but it's ultimately going
to come down to a doctor and that's the
problem mandating kids get this I'm like
sure what does the pediatrician say like
well that doesn't matter the government
decrees okay well you got to get out of
New York City and what's the risk and
what's the reward that people have to
individually think about for themselves
yep
all right Kevin Devine says my GF is
slowly dying of heart problems due to
the ca coveted measures she pays 500 a
month for insurance and has only been
and has only been seen by a doc once
still no referrals it's getting scary I
posted a short video on my YouTube about
it uh can you leave can you get out of
California before it's too late I don't
know that's crazy to do you know that's
like so she has health insurance but she
still can't see a doctor that's what
they're a legend yeah I guess so
harambee's Irish says you can tell it's
mostly liberals and Libertarians in here
all scared of the government like they
are God LOL I I don't think that's the
case I think so liberals libertarian me
like like us in here we're scared of the
government I mean we're mad at like
government overreach but I actually
think uh I respect the power certain
good things from government certain bad
things but I think it's mostly been bad
for a while yeah I think the founding
fathers had a lot of good ideas oh here
we go here's something interesting
monkey boy King says is Tim going to
take Dan bongino up on his offer to let
him explain what's going on with rumble
on Tim's show Dan bongino is welcome to
come on my show anytime he wants are you
kidding yes yeah Dan did an announcement
about the rumble uh sale but it was like
no there's no no details like he was
saying this is big this is great you
know we worked on this awesome and my
attitude was very much just like okay
well you know I don't see anything here
other than we're becoming exactly what
the problem was in the first place but
again competition is always good so like
I said net positive a competing powerful
force like an alternative place it's
going to force YouTube to be like okay
okay we're not going to censor everybody
otherwise we're going to lose them to
competition competition's a good thing
but yeah I'd love to have Dan bongino
want to talk about it that'd be great
um where is he based out of I want to
say Texas no Florida Florida Florida
um I mean he does his own show I don't
know if he'll be able to travel up here
because I'm pretty sure he does what
Monday through Friday as well yeah he
does you know but Dan you know we're
fans he's always he's always welcome to
come on
Adam
krzwinski probably pronouncing your name
wrong says we are on the edge of war
with Russia there have been several
cyber attacks by Russian actors the U.S
lost in Afghanistan Russia is invading
Ukraine diplomats are being sent home
talk about it Tim yes we actually did
have that lineup but maybe we'll do a
members only thing about that because we
didn't get to it but there's a lot of
news today and I think I'm going to do a
bigger thing on this tomorrow I had it
in the in the mix but then New York
announced their vax mandate and I'm just
like you know it's it's here at home
versus foreign policy stuff so I'm like
we got to talk about what's going on
with New York but uh definitely we will
get to that that's crazy 175 000 troops
I think are being reported Russian
troops in the Ukrainian border well it's
a build up on both sides so NATO and the
United States are also pushing their
soldiers there Russia has declared a red
line the United States has kind of uh
poked at it a little bit especially in
the in the in the sea there so it's back
and forth the kind of saber rattling
that's becoming louder and louder and
more dangerous for everyone involved
all right
ponton says guys we are all born into we
were all born into this it's been going
on the entire time it just surfaces as
it progresses this is generational
subversion realized we are in crisis
phase heading into normalization we stop
it now or they win
fourth turning man I think uh that
person has a point
yeah wolf freak says hey Tim you might
be interested to know I'm driving across
country and just hit a gas station that
required us to have a vax card they
denied me and my girlfriend's service
because we don't have one holy cow at a
gas station where was this that you
don't know but holy cow you can't get
gas you can't pump your own gas
New Jersey and Oregon I know ban you
can't pump your own gas yeah so if they
do it you know
hey J Seath says Tim will you get Dave
Rubin or Dan bongino on to discuss the
acquisition and going public would love
to see some hard questions they are both
welcome to come on anytime the problem
is they do their own shows right so it's
really difficult to be like hey cancel
your show fly over here and do my show
because it's just like yes you know it's
difficult and there have been people
like you know I think Elijah and Sydney
actually postponed their show to come on
here did they do that before I don't
recall I I think they may have and I
have tremendous respect for them for
being willing to do that no the last
time they were on was like a week before
they started no three days let them
prove their uh loyalty to us come on I
think I'm pretty sure mentioned like you
know we normally do the show here but I
want to come out to come on Tim's show
if okay maybe it's not true I don't know
either way like um Elijah and Sydney are
really really awesome and that was my
understanding and I was like really like
wow you guys that means so much to me
like thank you so much because they do
their show at the same time and and you
know we're big fans they're seven to
eight thirty those guys are awesome yeah
big fans they Kyle Rittenhouse on
earlier today yeah I know it was really
awesome yeah good show guys and you you
guys should come back Silas Kraft says
we in Germany had vaccinate equals
Freedom written on the dusseldorfer
television Tower we are preparing for
leaving Germany because of the coming
vaccine mandate my dad already lost his
job because of the test mandate and his
unwillingness to comply
yeah man
it's getting dark huh the Raptors
talents as I tried to start an honest
conversation with some people on a
Discord server well it started off nice
to say that it didn't end well as an
understatement people don't want an
honest conversation they want to win and
if that means the end of the world so be
it it's true for some people on the
right but it's mostly true for many on
the left it's the rule on the
establishment left and the left in
general and it's the exception on the
right for the most part and that's
likely because the right right now has a
sort of tacit alliance with Independence
and moderates and the more moderate
individuals be it right-leaning
conservative types and independent types
really want to understand and solve the
problems but you absolutely do have the
right zealous Trump must win no matter
what and screw you and what you have to
say however they're a small group
without institutional authorities so
they're allowed to have their opinion
same as the left problem is when the
establishment left aren't unwilling to
have a conversation and hold the reins
of power yo we got a big problem yeah if
you're if you're in a conversation via
text in that Discord chat don't put too
much weight on that it's hard to get any
good communication done via text but uh
if it was with words try listening more
if you can understand your opponent they
tend to like you a lot more and ask more
questions rather than making declarative
statements and if they disagree with you
call them racist
strategy everything there you go
Matthew Conley says for your pop culture
show if you need some retro gaming
Hardware I'm a collector that has 2.4 K
games across over 20 consoles just moved
into Martinsburg what would be the West
way to reach out to allow your team to
use my library well the pop culture show
is going to be focusing on like new
shows new games TV shows movies and kind
of stuff so there's a whole bunch of new
Netflix shows to talk about and review I
don't know if we would do Retro Gaming
stuff
so I don't I don't really know
Atari 2600 yeah shout out to berserk we
have a we have a Retron downstairs
what's that it's a it's like a remade
Nintendo and it plays Nintendo games
yeah it's pretty cool I think it plays
SNES too I don't know maybe I'm wrong
but you can just buy a box that like has
all the Nintendo games and SNES on it
just like plug it in your TV like we
have a Sega it's a little box you plug
it in it's got like a hundred Sega
Genesis games and I'm playing it now and
trying to playing on HD TV is just not a
thing yeah right yeah or I think it's
16-bit I had a 2600 as a kid yeah
I'm thinking of the games
oh yeah Pitfall man Pitfall 2 was
underrated all right let's see Spartan
bacon says Tim with a single action
revolver he could not have been able to
put a bullet in and then fire without
spinning the cylinder all the way around
I yeah I'm but I still I I still think
it's uh it makes more sense than this
wild scenario of crazy coincidences that
culminate with Helena Hutchins being
like point the gun at me and pull the
hammer back and I'm going you got it
bang oh no like I don't want to believe
that Alec Baldwin put a bullet in the
gun I don't want to believe it no I
think the angry crew member was like I'm
gonna get back at that production
company put a bullet in before they
walked off set but then like they said
you have to rotate the cylinder around
or pull the trigger you have to Fan the
hammer pull the trigger fan hammer or
rotate the cylinder to get the bolt to
go all the way around someone loaded it
and rotated it and then put it on the
table or Alec Baldwin did because Alec
Baldwin said if I manipulated it they
would have taken it away from me so why
didn't he then say if that was the
protocol hey who's this guy who's
manipulating this gun and bringing it to
me where's where's the prop guy who's
supposed to be handling it before I'm
giving it he he straight up said that so
then the only like simple explanation is
that
he put the bullet in it wound it you
know and got it ready and then he
so like that's premeditated no dude
that's insane it's hard to believe his
whole career are you telling me the
alternative is more believable I think
so what the alternative that an angry
crew member put a bullet in the gun got
it set up and then and then Helena
Hutchins was like I know you're not
supposed to use the gun right now but
why don't you point today it might have
been a lot because they're like you said
someone said earlier there's more crew
members are going to be there watching
that moment so I want to see if people
come out and acknowledge that that did
happen but the one crew member who was
there watching it was the guy in charge
of weapons so how does that no no no no
no that was that was Hannah Goodyear's
read I think yeah the armor did not give
Baldwin the gun but I'm sure the armor
was there on set so what point is the
armor like how did you get the gun like
I don't know if she was there my job is
to give it to you if it's not in my
possession and it's for the production
assistant then I already screwed up
because it shouldn't leave my possession
anyway so it shouldn't have happened the
official story is that someone
accidentally the armor must have
accidentally put bowling in it and then
left it unattended and the A.D who
wasn't supposed to have it take took it
brought it to Alec Baldwin who knew if
it was not the prop guy it had to be
given back to them he straight up said
this and then Helena Hutchins who was
shot and killed told Alec Baldwin I
you're not supposed to have the gun out
in this scene but I want to film you
pulling it out anyway also pull the
hammer back right now and point it at me
that's just I'm sorry dude I don't want
to believe Alec Baldwin did this it
seems crazy to think Alec Baldwin the
guy from 30 Rock took a gun put a ball
in it and then went bang but it's
crazier to assume all of that ridiculous
stuff happened I don't think it's crazy
to assume that an angry crew member that
was about to walk off set loaded one of
the guns before they left and then Alec
Baldwin was told by Helena Hutchins
point the gun at me pull the hammer back
and then shoot it in a scene where the
gun's not needed that's very that's why
I can understand and it look but if you
want to claim an anger crew member
sabotaged Alec Baldwin that's or someone
yeah you're making more assumptions
right and so the least amount of
assumptions we can make is that Alec
Baldwin pulled a gun and shot a woman
that's just that's for sure I mean
that's Undisputed at this point but then
how did the ball get in there I don't
know he had a gun it did not come from
the armorer let's just put it this way
it didn't come from the armor the gun
did not come from the onset armorer
right there it should have been red
flags Galore that's all that matters red
flag Alec bald was holding a gun that
did not come from the armor uses a prop
and then he pointed a woman pulled the
hammer back and she was shot it's like
giving a girl you don't know what a bar
or drink and saying like here you go the
girl's gonna say I'm gonna throw this on
the ground because I don't know where it
came from right if you're the actor and
they're like here's your gun and be like
no no no if you give assumptions yeah
like you're gonna cross the street and
you ask the guy is any traffic coming
he's like no there's no traffic I'm
still not gonna walk out on the street
with a blindfold on I'm gonna stick the
blindfold off and look both ways for
myself let's just talk very simple fact
right now Alec Baldwin had a gun that
did not come from the onset armorer he
then pointed it at a woman in a scene
that did not call for him to point it at
someone or you or use it pulled the
hammer back and the gun was fired I
didn't say he pulled the trigger or fire
the gun the gun was fired these are
indisputable facts everything else is US
speculating or making assumptions I
didn't say he loaded it I don't know how
the bolt got in there but he had a gun
that didn't come from the armorer he
pulled it out when he wasn't supposed to
pulled the hammer back and pointed at
the woman it fired and and she was
killed why would anyone make any
assumption other than Alec Baldwin
pulled out a gun that he did not get
from from the farmer and he killed a
woman with it the immediate assumption
should be why did he kill the woman not
what what strange Final Destination type
circumstances can we can we build up to
make it seem like it was all one big
silly accident and they lied to us from
the get-go it was a blanket misfired
shrapnel hitter and all those dumb lies
misfired yeah and now we'll and that's
how misfire means and now we know it was
Alec Baldwin pulling a gun in a scene he
wasn't supposed to yeah he wasn't
supposed to use it he pulled the hammer
back pointed at a woman the gun did not
come from the set department and he is
it that he was supposed to have the gun
in the scene and he was supposed to pull
it out but he wasn't supposed to point
it he the uh script supervisor and
electrician who were both suing said the
scene did not call for him to use the
gun
that's so weird but then Helena Hutchins
asked him to pull it out no he made that
up here he's lying well he's lying again
all these people were on set so a lot of
other people who's the other guy who was
shot the the director yeah if that
director is conscious he is yeah that
director was pretty close he must have
heard anything that was said right I
mean he's right over her shoulder yeah
so she told him to point the gun he's
going to be standing there listen I
think it's just I don't look I think I
think it's crazy to believe that Al
Baldwin killed the lady but it's crazier
to make up all this stuff to justify why
he didn't and it's also crazy that his
wife pretended she was from Spain
right I mean it's like this is a couple
known to be Liars think about how
desperate people are to claim Alec
Baldwin did not kill intentionally kill
this woman she pretended she didn't know
the word for cucumber in English she
really really at the cooking show in the
Today Show she was making gazpacho from
her Homeland and she's like and now I
add the uh how you say in English
cucumber you're from Boston why are you
why are you faking this Spanish accent
that's weird making us Macho
how you say in English Hollywood
cucumber you can see it on YouTube it's
hysterical
All Right End of Time says don't forget
everyone 2024 right in Tim for president
Luke for VP Sour Patch lid for Secretary
of health and Ian for Tim's science
advisor uh no thank you don't waste your
phone we're near office this year
all right
Massimo kloka says Tim look up the novel
Lolita by Vladimir not Nabokov I wonder
why it's called the Lolita Express
interesting yeah that's a connection
it's gross we know
lady Char reacts says what are your
thoughts on the proposed rep legislation
to require schools teach the history of
communism
I mean they don't it'd be freaking
awesome if they do like I learned about
this when I was in school like we were
just out of the Cold War I mean I was
going to school during the Cold War I
didn't actually was I was yeah I think I
was in first grade I I got Tom a little
bit about the Soviet Union and about
communism bad but not about like
communist atrocity not about Karl Marx I
didn't know who Karl Marx very little
about China yeah
[Music]
was it 93 when the Soviet Union
collapsed 89 is when the wall fell yeah
really yeah oh okay when did officially
collapse Union Luke you know um was it
91 or 93 91 yeah what's your last one
okay then I wasn't in school or was I
yeah yeah you're like
yeah that would put me in preschool and
kindergarten yeah in first grade yeah
yeah that'd be first grade yep yeah I
thought so yeah crazy I watched the
Challenger blow up in first grade that
was weird I remember Ross Perot and like
I didn't know what it meant but the
school asked us to like type in a
computer who we'd vote for and I guess
they were like trying to figure out what
our parents were saying about it so I
was like raspberry yeah my parents were
like the two-party system and like
slamming the table okay yeah did they
vote for Ross Perot also uh I don't know
if they actually did
um I don't know I think my mom was
Voting Democrat my dad was Voting
Republican but I don't know about back
then I don't know about back then I
think in 2000 that's what happened like
my mother was Democrat my dad went
Republicans a lot of what he said has
come to fruition Ross Pro is a lot like
Ron Ron Paul back in the day I mean when
he talked about NAFTA and this giant
sucking sound of jobs leaving North
America to go to other places and we're
gonna have a respite he talked about how
middle of America will be decimated
wolf Rick says hey Tim that station I
was denied service at was in Fort
Collins Colorado
Fort Collins very very uh wow all right
ninja crazy ninja Tanuki says if Alex
finger was on the trigger when he pulled
the hammer back and it was original or a
original fixed firing pin model story is
plausible still no excuse right so what
that means is Alec Baldwin was
depressing the trigger while he pulled
the oh and that then it just releases
right away so it just flicked back that
sounds legit that sounds plausible Alec
Baldwin was holding the gun gripping the
trigger tight maybe or like maybe a hair
was a hairline trigger what are those
called hair trigger well it is a very
light press
very light press and then he pulled it
back and possible but that would mean
he's violating all standard safety
protocols on on top of the protocols
he's already violated I mean look look
just to put it very simply involuntary
manslaughter I think is a given he did
not receive the gun from the onset
armorer right so what is this gun whose
was it where did it come from why would
he assume anything
he wasn't doing his job he wasn't taking
safety seriously and he admitted to
George Stephanopoulos he knew that if
someone else other than the prop guy was
manipulating the gun they'd have to give
it back to the prop guy so he gets
handed a gun from some random person and
goes ah click bang oops
involuntary manslaughter at the very
least
to a post with that says New York forces
medical procedures despite lack of
testing and risk concerns meanwhile
fauci confirms illegal immigrant
Southern border crossers are immune from
federal travel bans and testing
requirements the Republic is dying yeah
that's one of the things about kova
that's been driving me nuts is the
amount of people coming across the
border that aren't getting tested and
then getting sent in and I'm not like a
bullish on covid but I'm just like that
glaring hypocrisy is insane yeah and
fauci's response was that's an entirely
separate issue it's a good phone I mean
that is like if you would talk about a
pandemic and National Security letting
people into your country during a
pandemic and just letting them fly and
then and then shipping them
strategically all throughout the country
right I mean because they can't leave
them all in Texas and so they'll fly by
nights drop 500 in Dulles they'll drop a
couple hundred in Miami so yeah this is
such a serious pandemic that we're just
gonna spread it we gotta we got one here
and I think this is a good one for Luke
End of Time says I'm wanting to get into
journalism would you by chance have any
references is an educational material
which would help me with the craft I
feel like more honest people need to
start getting involved yeah I have
change media University which is now
free for Lucan censored.com members but
uh it goes you it goes through all the
basic kind of lessons and it goes
through uh how to how to start your
career how to how to do things but it's
it's very difficult it's not an easy one
it's becoming more and more difficult
because of big Tech's uh online
censorship so it's very difficult for
anyone to make a name for themselves
especially with the algorithms being
rigged against you so my word of advice
is if if you really do have a passion
for it go after it but also have a side
hustle or a side job that will help you
pay for bills and facilitate that kind
of lifestyle of you doing what you
really love to do because when you're in
this business right now you really have
to love it and if you love it enough you
can make anything possible you can make
it happen and if if you're committed
enough if you truly believe in yourself
enough you can make that a reality for
yourself very easily we just got to work
hard and it takes work and sacrifice and
it's not easy you got to figure it out
and build it up but you can succeed so
with that being said my friends go to
timcast.com and support our work so we
can continue to do this journalism we
just hired another reporter who's
handling out of breaking news stories
and we're just going to keep growing and
expanding we've gotten new paperwork for
our two nonprofits one on fact checking
the fact Checkers and one on creating
decentralized Tech those are going to be
kicking up into full speed the end of
the year when we can officially start
bringing in you know donors and and
actually funding this stuff and it's
non-profit open source so there's no
there's no ownership there's no giving
anything away there's no Banning people
we're gonna you know do our best to make
sure we Empower people to know the truth
and share information they see fit so
thank you for all of your support at
timcast.com that's where your resources
go to hiring journalists making new
shows building culture and uh fact
checking the fact Checkers Building
Technology you can follow the show at
timcastiro basically everywhere smash
that like button don't forget to
subscribe to this Channel and you can
follow me personally at timcast you know
everywhere follow me on Instagram if
you'd like and uh Daniel you want to
show anything out it was great to be
here thanks again for having me Daniel
Turner PTF on all platforms and always a
pleasure to be with you fine folks
having these these robust conversations
we need more of it it was great thanks
for coming on and I have my own media
organization and platform on Luke
uncensored.com where I released a video
today and I released another public one
on youtube.com forward slash we are
change where I had way too much fun and
screamed way too much we are change on
YouTube thanks for having me on thanks
for coming everyone I love you Daniel
great to see you again man Tim hey
thanks again for this uh yeah it looks
good quality outfit it makes it makes
you like really pop out of the room yeah
like an Ian kind of it's very
Christmassy yeah yeah or like a gray
dark room everyone wears like gray dark
colors but like I was like
yeah it's perfect it's flavorful yeah
here I am in my black sweater and
contrast Ian I was gonna say before we
go that um if you guys really really
want awesome hot dogs you need to go to
Iceland because they're in every single
gas station you can get them with like
50 million they take their hot dogs very
seriously really yes you need to go to
ice you want to hear a crazy story when
I went when I went to Iceland we were
like in between uh Reykjavik and that uh
Blue Lagoon place or whatever and
there's like a there's like a hamburger
joint and I went in there and it was
like just me and a friend and like
literally no one else and two guys we
order food we're eating burgers and two
guys walk in and then the one guy was
just like hey you're Tim pool and I was
like oh yeah man he's like oh wow and I
think I think he was saying he was from
like the US and he was there visiting
and just it was like the weirdest thing
to be in the middle of nowhere it's like
volcanic rock everywhere and there's a
burger joint it's a crazy story it is
very much like being on another planet I
really recommend you yeah it smells like
farts it does but it's cool there's
beautiful things there anyway you guys
can follow me on Twitter at Sour Patch
Lids thanks so uh our our uh our our
tomorrow's guest is officially confirmed
and all that yes correct we can announce
it yeah oh yeah Steve bannon's coming
back yeah Pearl Harbor day so we're
gonna we're gonna have Steve Bannon here
and we got a lot to talk about uh
especially with what's going on yes and
here's the crazy thing about what's
going on with Bannon the subpoenas the
charges the entirety of the mainstream
media has his back
really like this is this is the weirdest
thing really he filed he wants to get
all these documents released and all the
media companies were like we agree we
want to see all the documents pertaining
to his case and the FEDS are like no
shut it down stop huh so this is going
to be a lot of fun so really excited to
have Steve here again Mr Bannon and um
thanks for coming and for everybody else
make sure you tune in for that show but
go to timcast.com we're gonna have that
member segment coming up in just a bit
just a minute smash that like button on
the way out and we will see you all
there bye guys